foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
check one two one two one two
foreign
[Music]
people of the internet
welcome
to Retro raconteur live folks
everybody's always like did you change
your background no I'm just desk is
raised tonight been sitting too much
today reading all your comments
so tonight we stand
and yeah back-to-back nights I mean I
don't know it's like something something
happened today
you guys know anything about this let me
turn down the music a little bit we'll
keep it going though because I just love
this uh
common room music it's so good
so good
all right but welcome guys thank you all
for being here to an extra special
edition
we normally stream on Tuesday evenings
for anyone new here welcome to Retro
reckon Tour live we do this every week
every Tuesday we did it last night
last night though we um
we had a little recap of the unbreakable
vow and and that's importance in the
Harry Potter series and the consequences
of breaking
an unbreakable vowel so we had to talk
about that
but today tonight this morning wherever
whatever it may be for you
the unbreakable vow has been fulfilled
ladies and gentlemen how are you the
unbreakable vowel has been fulfilled
so it's time to talk Hogwarts sexy man
it's time to talk gameplay it's time to
talk all about the trip to La welcome
first off
before I even get to
the comments and the chats and
everything I have to thank you guys
first and foremost thank you guys
everybody watching right now
anybody who watches this later on replay
because without you guys I have I mean I
have no doubt one of the reasons I was
even asked to do this is because of our
community that we have here it's because
of you guys for making this possible man
I mean and it really is I really do mean
that
uh last night we had we were having a
lot of donations and I just I stopped to
say guys look
no matter what whether you some people
don't have the money to donate and
that's not an expectation you do not
have to Super Chat you don't have to be
a member you don't even have to to chat
I mean literally just by you being here
checking out the streams I have no doubt
that WB and Avalanche notice those kinds
of things so thanks to you guys without
without you it wouldn't have even been
possible uh then thanks to WB for
inviting me out we had such a great time
such a great time it was it was a very
short amount of time but we accomplished
a lot a lot in a very short amount of
time I want to talk about all the stuff
that happened like
outside I mean we're gonna talk gameplay
I know that's why you guys are here but
I want to talk to you about all the just
the conversations that we had with a lot
of the creators and all a little bit of
the behind the scenes stuff if you will
I've got some pictures we're gonna show
here in a bit that I haven't shared
anywhere else yet I've got the gameplay
footage you guys
I I was talking to expect to go I need
to start I realize I need to start
saying his name or his his channel name
whenever I refer to him on stream look I
say James some people maybe new not know
who he is a lot of people know James AKA
expect to go
he he and I were in the same gameplay
session together and immediately after
we got done we were just like
I don't even know what my video is going
to be
I don't know what footage I'm going to
use
I don't even know where to start because
we saw an experience so much
so I hope you guys were pleased with the
preview video that we put out today
I also put out a second video that was
just like a full uninterrupted gameplay
of the story Mission so I know some
people are already like okay this is way
too much if you don't want to know
anything about at all about the story I
get it I totally get it
um but yeah we were talking after like I
don't know where to start so in addition
to all that I've already released I
still have
I would say a full hour of footage
a full hour I would say of stuff that I
haven't I haven't shown
and what maybe is blowing me away the
most about watching I was watching so
many videos today from these other
awesome creators is we all like played
the same two hours and everybody had had
at least one new thing in every video
which I think is a testament to to the
creators out there really but also to
the game that Avalanche has built like
we played the same two hours we did the
same stuff and yet we had in some cases
completely different experiences picked
up on completely different things uh
hello been snow fire tornado didn't get
that in mind didn't get that in mind
don't know how you got that
all right let's let's uh welcome and see
who's here hanging out so oh my gosh
before we even started
before we even started we have several
new subscribers to the channel so
welcome thank you guys so much for
subscribing and then let's see I want to
make sure we didn't miss any of the
members
oh my gosh you guys started real wizard
Harry it's like 54 50 minutes before we
went live okay hold on scrolling
scrolling scrolling
scrolling okay there we go sit three
with the five months thank you so much
sithre oh wait hold on
[Music]
we can't forget the hammer
welcome to house tracking tour welcome
back to house tracking tour for Sith Ray
Reuben with the six months Reuben thank
you so much my friend thank you very
much welcome to house wreck and tour
welcome back I should say then Owen with
the five tier one memberships guys I
just have to pause for a second can
the the mods on the channel here
please like
I can't think particularly Nico elwin do
so much for this channel so much for
this channel that goes a lot of times
unnoticed so it's gonna be crazy there's
gonna be a lot I mean if you guys have a
comment that gets removed you know we're
trying to protect people from bigger
spoilers art book stuff we're not
talking about any of that and the mods
really do have a tough job they do a lot
of stuff in the Discord as well
um so Elwyn and Nico as well as
Stargazer Tim Dylan Christy
the mods they just they do so much so
thank you to the mods for all your all
your support and everything you guys do
to help make the channel go and then L
win of course with the five gifteds
thank you very much Owen let's say we
had Austin Scott becoming a member of
House wrecking tour through that gift of
membership from Elwyn Jaden Nicole
Cooper all with gifted memberships right
there so guys what happens when you get
a membership you get to use the emoji in
the chat and we have some pretty fun
Wizarding World emojis which by the way
I think I think we've unlocked some more
after last night and then after this
especially pretty sure we have volte
multi thank you so much for the Super
Chat and welcome back volte poppy is an
evil retro just for today though
yeah
you guys watch the gameplay man if you
watch that story mission
I'm just saying
poppy can be pretty she can be pretty
fierce when she needs to be
Raven quality Tyrell with the Super Chat
as well a Ravenclaw Tyrell thank you so
much for the Super Chat congrats on the
40K I know we did yeah we passed 40K
subs today guys
40K Subs so thank you all very much for
that
big big milestone and then speaking of
starkey's or Tim himself another
moderator here starkees or Tim also
gifting five memberships Tim thank you
so much dude
and congrats to Lando Taylor nymph and
Ella Dora all getting memberships
welcome all of you welcome to house
tracking Tour by the power of Thor's
hammer here you were officially member
of House track and tour enjoy uh let's
see what else do you get special Discord
roll you get discounts on our merch if
you want something like this retro hat
and you get the cool Emoji but really
memberships are just a way to kind of
show some love and support to creators
Draco with the Super Chat can't gift
memberships
so here's a Super Chat love today's
videos Draco thank you my friend I I put
so much thought into especially the
preview video today because well like I
said I was talking with expecto go just
trying to even decide
where do where do we even start like
where do we even start I want to do this
game Justice I want to talk about
everything that looks amazing which
there's a lot I want to show the stuff
that you know might be a little bit
concerning too
but most of all I want to do right by
you guys I tried to ask questions that I
knew you guys were interested in that's
why we tried to show off stuff like
swimming obviously
uh the little the little fountain
if you guys know that was a fountain
where a lot of people were saying oh
that little prompt means you can sit
there
I had to go over and test it and so it's
not a Sit button it was not a Sit button
it's an interact you interact with that
Fountain and then once you get that
Fountain spinning there's a little spot
that you can uh you get a little uh page
right there a page from the oh my gosh I
can't think of the name of the book
right now but yeah you guys know what
I'm talking about
the book that the ministry gives you a
couple more subscriptions coming in as
well thank you guys for the subs
Dr sherbet with the Super Chat as well
Chandler wood is here yo is Chandler
here hey we're gonna talk a little about
Chandler man I almost I was so mad
because it looked like I was not gonna
get to meet Chandler and Eric
but I'll tell I'll tell you guys about
it it had a good it had a good finish
here had a good finish thank you Dr
Sherbert for the Super Chat fetch Quest
gaming with the five dollar Super Chat
let's see the extra footage yeah yeah
we're gonna we're gonna get to it we're
gonna get to it for sure
because there's like I still have to go
through all of it I've watched it all
you're a wizard Harry but I want to go
through all of it and try to figure out
what else I can make videos on one of
them I already have ready to go that's
what we're going to look at tonight so
if you guys know the uh and it's like a
minor it's not like a big story or
anything it's a little side quest sort
of like a little mini puzzle it's the
one with the little moth so I showed a
little bit of it in my video today but
I'm gonna show you guys like the the
full thing for it from start to finish
and then I'll show you some behind the
scenes pictures as well that we got
Moon Lily with a super chat as well I
was laughing so much when you went
straight to the water test out swimming
mechanic and then Chandler swimsuit was
awesome right I know I saw those tweets
too
it's so good
so good oh my gosh guys like Hagrid's
working overtime tonight
welcome to all the new witches and
wizards thank you guys William Sullivan
with a super chat as well thank you
William notice I'm popping with textures
during your footage no this is the final
build how noticeable is it during your
time with the game
so I tried to point out a couple of them
in the video
I like the texture pop in truthfully
while I was playing it
didn't notice it much at all the one
that I noticed that I pointed out in the
video is when the people just kind of
appeared when I land on that one let's
just pull it up let's just pull it up
let's go ahead and let's Dive In
let's just dive in folks all right so
I'm gonna go to uh let's see that's the
wrong wizard channel right here
all right let's just pull it up here
so after all this time it wands at the
red yeah that's that's me that's me
oh my gosh why is it doing that
all right there we go okay let's go
ahead and switch views here
you're a wizard Harry oh my goodness
Hagrid Hagrid working overtime tonight
people working overtime
okay so the one that I I was first of
all
right up front I was playing on PS5
performance mode I believe I believe I'm
pretty sure that most of the footage you
guys are gonna see is gonna be in the
Fidelity mode from other creators I
don't know that for a fact but I'm I
know for a fact that the default where I
played the default was the Fidelity mode
which is only 30 FPS of course it's
going to look better
but I'm all about the frame rate and I
know so many of you are it's like I get
why you know when when Publishers show
off the game they want to show off like
the best visuals right for screenshots
and stuff like that makes sense
but we had to actually ask we had James
I know James for sure expect to go we
both asked and said hey do you mind if
we play in the in the performance mode
they they allowed us to do that so we
both played in performance
and then the other thing I will say and
I know this is gonna sound like I'm
I'm like Shilling for the game it's not
that it is I've learned a lot about
video codex this past weekend and
compression that sort of thing
but the footy the footage that is on
YouTube
I promise you guys does not look as good
as what's actually like like the raw
footage that I got on my SD card it
looks better it look it looks better and
I tried to get it as close as I possibly
could with my exports and everything but
it really does it looks even better now
is it it's not like a huge drastic
difference but yeah I can definitely
tell a difference so the question there
from William was about about popping and
such so the only one that I really
noticed big time during the gameplay
itself was killed was this that we were
playing on we've been told that it is
not right different times to me so it's
not this does not have the day one patch
it's right here right here to stop at
this little spot right here so see
nobody over there see these students
kind of just appear out of nowhere and
then there they are flying in and then
once I link so that was the only one I
noticed when I went back and watched I
noticed another weird kind of little um
there's one moment in the poppy Quest
where I actually don't even think it's
in this one I think it's in my other one
I think it's in my other one where uh
you see like the main character kind of
just like shift over for some reason
but my first thought as soon as they put
the controller in my hands
we're ready is I was like this looks
better than anything I've seen so far
this looks better than anything I've
seen so far it looks better than what
you're seeing right now too YouTube
compression and all that I even made
sure this was 4K because the footage we
had was 4K and everything's 60fps and
all that
but um it looked so good we were on I
think there were probably about 27 inch
24 inch probably 27 inch monitors or so
I believe they were Razer monitors and
then it was on PS5 and they put the
control on my hand and so the first
thing we saw was like the character
creator
and it's just like
oh my gosh just looking at the character
model in the Character Creator and then
when we actually got in game
I was
I was pleasantly surprised I'll be
honest with you guys pleasantly
surprised not perfect
but it just felt I was so happy that it
felt smooth man so happy that it felt
smooth because I'm like if it if there's
a lot of frame rate dips it gets to me
but thank you William for the Super Chat
thank you for all the new Subs that are
that are jumping in as well uh Elwyn
with the Super Chat yo thank you oh and
guys shout out and show your love for
Mrs raconteur without her support retro
couldn't do anything this is very true
very true
very true shout out to Mrs ranking tour
maybe someday you guys can warm her up
enough to get her to maybe like let her
hand appear on stream or even just her
voice
she's like she's a little bit camera shy
so maybe one day maybe one day but thank
you Elwyn fetch Quest gaming any word on
if the music in Hogwarts Legacy is
copyright free and thank you for the
Super Chat fetch Quest so
Chandler answered this on Twitter if
you're um because fetch Quest I'm pretty
sure you're a Creator right I'm pretty
sure it's all good I'm pretty sure like
don't quote me on that but
um Chandler told us if you ever get like
a like uh not a strike but a um a claim
just to reach out to them and they can
take a look and get you on like a a
white list or something where they they
uh can set it to where you won't get
that anymore but yeah I've never had any
problems
Sith right with the Super Chat good to
see you here Sith Ray what was one thing
that shocked me while playing
oh okay well there was a lot I mean I
think my biggest jaw-dropping moment
and if you guys don't want to know any
stories spoilers here's what we're going
to do it's like minor stuff but I'm
gonna put my hands over my ears when I'm
about to say something and then I'll
I'll take it back off when I'm done
okay so the thing that shocked me the
most was
when we opened the tent
when we open the tent and found the
dragon fighting ring
I
mean okay now we're good you can come
back that part
my jaw dropped my jaw because I it was
just so unexpected you know we're
walking along there we get to the tent
and then excuse me what what
yeah my jaw dropped at that part
totally dropped
couldn't couldn't believe it I mean
because we've only seen one of those so
far right and all the lead up all the
build up to this game we'd only seen one
of those and then right there you go in
and there's two completely different
ones yeah
that was a big moment noisy boy with a
super chat first of all Told You So said
you'd be invited to something like this
secondly do you think we can use the
Elder one at some point okay so that
one's hard to answer
possible spoilers
Quest not related to this event not
related to this event just be clear
about that
oh it's hard to answer that one without
spoiling people it's possible it's
possible there have been there's been a
couple leaks alluding to one or possibly
more of the Deathly Hallows so we'll
just leave it at that we'll leave it at
that I will say
the new shirt that I got not this one
which this is a uh this is also this is
my other Hogwarts Legacy shirt that I
got from Amazon
which by the way that is official merch
if you guys didn't know
Chandler was able to confirm that but
people were saying the wand on my little
hoodie they're like that's the Elder one
I said I don't think so or unless it's
like an earlier version of the Elder one
it looks to me like the exact same one
that's in the uh collector's edition the
ancient magic wand that's the one it
looks like to me
but thank you for your support Noisy Boy
very much appreciate it very much
appreciate it
Moon Lily with a super chat as well how
smooth is the flying did you try it melt
so we didn't get to try any mounts lines
for that one first we did not get to try
any mounts the very first thing we did
though like after the character
Creations we we got to fly on the Broom
accio first and so if you remember when
they first showed off the broom they
talked about how they wanted it to feel
like not
the most advanced broom like it's not
supposed to feel like you're hopping on
a fireball here from Harry's day it's
not supposed to feel like that so at
first when you first hop on I was like
this is kind of a little bit sluggish
and you can move you know using the left
stick and right stick like you can make
it go and it just felt kind of slow and
then I asked I was like there's a
there's a speed boost right yeah it's R2
so you hold R2 and then that's when I
actually let me go back here
yeah
let me go back see if we can get some so
like right there I'm just kind of
gliding normally that's no R2
that's no R2 right there
all right then if I get to another scene
here
I'm pretty sure it's coming up right
or it might be before that actually
so that when you see the little Trail
coming okay right there you see how you
see how I pulled back here let's rewind
that a little bit so you guys can see it
better
Sports Legacy and also play the game
myself for a two so when you see that
little Trail okay so see I'm kind of
leaning forward you got the trail so I'm
holding R2 right there
so that may that it feels much better
but it doesn't feel like it's not super
precise it's not super tight tight
controls right there which I think is
intentional and then here we go right
right about
there I let go of R2 so now I'm kind of
just in this little hover or a wizard
position and then you can just sort of
you know you can fly around really slow
like that if you just want to take in
the surrounding area
but but they didn't talk about at this
event but the other thing they've
already confirmed is the fact that you
can upgrade the broom
so we're going to unlock broom upgrades
to possibly change all that stuff all
that stuff but yeah very good question
very good question
Elwyn with another Super oh no wait hold
on hold on you're a wizard Harry Gleason
cook with the five dollar super check
Gleason I don't see a comment with it
thank you so much buddy for the Super
Chat very much appreciated
and then uh vanity of Eli send a five
dollar Super Chat thank you very much
was anything said or did you see
anything about being able to manually
make it day or night like resting or
something I did not and I think I even
said maybe it was on Twitter where I
answered somebody everything I saw was
day
but it might have been
oh I've watched so many videos today of
people of creators who put this out I
don't want to get this wrong somebody's
video that I was watching I want to say
they had night night time footage and I
wanted to ask them where did you get
that
be able to die I can't remember who it
was though
but yeah I I never no one ever mentioned
that to me I think based on what they've
said before I think all of that is going
to be story based I could be wrong like
like chapter based If You Remember When
Alan was talking and the gameplay
showcases about
um how everything's sort of set up by
the narrative right so my take and again
this this is not I didn't see anything
on this at the event my take is that it
will be like story based so like when
you cross a specific Mission then
Hogwarts will turn tonight or it could
even be like the old school Potter games
remember where you like you could do all
you all you want to do for that day and
then you end the day and then it goes
tonight I could I could see it being
something like that
fast travel points and then we had elwin
with a super chat 771 people yo dude 771
that might be a record that might be a
record hit that like button oh and says
guys yes thank you so much for the likes
helps more people find the video
um and when we do 100 I'm pretty sure we
already hit 100 likes but when we do a
hundred
we do a random Harry Potter quote trivia
and then when we hit 200 we do a um
oh my gosh an impersonation
impersonation from the Harry Potter
series that chat tells me what to do
Chad tells me what to do and I obey
sometimes Ellen thank you for the Super
Chat and guys thank you so much for the
likes then we had uh Nico with a super
chat James wants you to tell a story
about you went into the wrong Studio oh
yeah
okay okay here we go that's that's good
actually all right let's get was it
wizard PhD
was it wizard PhD okay I'm gonna have to
ask her then
because I I was thinking it was her and
I didn't want to get it wrong Jack
fraggs has nighttime footage too nightly
Sinister thank you for the Super Chat
yes Wizard PhD she watches a lot if
she's here I'd love to know how she got
that would love to know okay so here's
some behind the scenes stuff for you
guys
so the day of the event
uh James and I rode over together again
James expect to go I need I want to make
sure I say the name of his channel so
it's just so his channel gets plugged
anytime I bring him up but I just I know
him as James so we went over and we went
to the wrong side
it was like on one side of the road was
the WB Studio Tour on the other side of
the road was where we're actually
supposed to be
and I'm terrible directions you guys
know I say that on stream all the time
Mrs raconteur knows this all too well so
I was just like following James like
yeah whatever whatever they said and we
go in there and so we go in and they had
all this like Wizarding World stuff and
so you know James and I we just start
getting like oh what's this what's that
so here's one picture
the tri-wizard cup
so we're just walking around looking at
all the stuff they have in there
there's one of them right there
and I think we were supposed to be on
the eighth floor
and so there were some security guards
in there and we said where how do we get
up to the uh eighth floor we're here for
uh WB Games thing and they said uh there
is no eighth floor here oh wait a second
we're supposed to be across the road
but it was fine they they waited for us
we made it on time so we we went back
across the road dude I know I had
another picture of us being in that uh
oh wait maybe it was a video
yeah let's do VLC here
oh come on VLC come on VLC
here it is so they had like this Black
Adam stuff so James and I mean we're
just hanging out we're just like oh this
all looks cool
this stuff looks awesome in here so
we're getting photos getting video
it was the uh it was a WB Studio Tour
though that's where we were
we were in there by accident
okay this might be a video
let me see what this video is
oh that's when we were at Universal that
video right there yeah we'll talk about
that too we'll talk about Universal too
that was that was later everything runs
in my head because I was literally there
I think about
hold on I got in
at
well let's just do let's do that let's
do a chronological recap of the trip
here hold on though another Super Chat
from uh Gleason did I get to see how big
the map was
or a wizard Harry okay Gleason here's
where this is where I failed you guys
this is where I failed I forgot to pull
up the map I forgot to pull up the mat
however however even if I had pulled up
the map we wouldn't have been able to
show it we wouldn't be able to show it
they didn't want to showing off any
menus because a lot of the menus that
pulled up like still had Dev code stuff
in there so they had to jump us to
different sections of the game so they
just said no menus other than you know
stuff that we'd already seen was fine or
like menus like this was fine
so I couldn't be I couldn't have showed
it even if I had but um
I think Ben I think Benjamin snow pulled
up the map a couple times
and I want to say there was another
video I saw they they talked about
opening up the uh the map as well
but yeah I was kicking myself that I
didn't do that kicking myself that I
didn't do that Supernova with a super
chat as well thank you Supernova for the
sport what part of another math question
part of the map are you most excited to
see more of well so we were limited in
our footage to like just the Hogwarts
grounds
and so I flew around I knew I wanted to
go around the Quidditch Stadium because
I knew people would be curious like can
you even fly in there so I did that but
I want to see all the Forbidden Forest
stuff like if I had to pick one spot
that we haven't seen
I want to see The Forbidden Forest and
be and because we don't really I mean we
don't even know
wait we don't know how far it extends
like there's still some questions about
do we actually go to Azkaban at some
point we're pretty sure we go to
Gringotts we see that like through the
little portal in the trailer pretty and
we see us kind of riding on the cart
we're pretty sure we go there at some
point like when do all those things
happen right
game and like if I had if I had to pick
any location
if I had to pick just one I'd say
Ministry of magic
but as far as like kind of in the
surrounding area of Hogwarts yeah I want
to see what all they're hiding in the
Forbidden Forest what all are they
hiding in there that's what I want to
see
but thank you Supernova appreciate it
appreciate it okay so
oh this is a good story to tell James if
you're still here this uh James was
talking about this earlier in history
when we all started finding out like did
you get an email did you get an email
about this
I kid you not guys I kid you not
I want to say we got it around December
sometime
it was a Tuesday
on a stream night
I had just hit the go live button
and whenever I hit go live I had like a
10 minute countdown
I had just hit go live
uh I have a bathroom it's like right on
the opposite like on the other side of
this wall so it's very close I went out
started my countdown went out went to
the restroom came back in
checked my phone
I was like you know just like habit
checking my email
and I I thought it was a joke I thought
it was a joke at first
for because the email it doesn't come
from the email you would think it would
come from
so I was kind of like what
it seemed very official the way it was
word and everything seemed very official
but I still you know I'm just skeptical
by Nature so
the countdown's ticking it's like two
minutes before I'm supposed to start
streaming
and my jaw is just kind of what
so I'm like okay I just have to like
take this out of my brain right now
separate it put that put this into
another section of my brain
and I'll think about this later
do go through the whole two two and a
half hour stream James oh my gosh expect
to go he's been up over how many hours
now have you been up James how many
hours I just have to force it for my
brain so I force it for my brain go
through the whole stream
and then I like my DMs are blowing up
James is like retro exclamation point
retro more exclamation check your email
have you checked your email
and then I knew then I knew it was legit
I knew it was legit so we've known we've
known about this for a little bit now we
had to go all through like the holidays
and new year's like waiting
because they said we'll have more info
in the new year
so we go all through that
we had like two days for for the people
that were in La there were I think there
were two different sessions you could
pick from and we were trying to
coordinate a little bit so we could all
be there at the same time I just picked
Thursday because it was better for my
work schedule
but then I said I was going to talk
about Chandler later Chandler and Eric
so I found out later Chandler and Eric
were actually wanting to meet me the
night before like like a Tuesday night
into Wednesday
and I wasn't gonna be flying until to
Wednesday like late late Wednesday
and they had some other stuff they had
to go take care of they were heading out
well I think Chandler post I think he
tweeted a picture so I think I could say
it yeah they were flying out across the
country somewhere else and so it didn't
look like I was gonna get to meet
Chandler and Eric at all I was so bummed
but Chandler had said he told me kind of
what time their flight was leaving my
flight got in a little bit early and in
their flight I think their flight got
pushed back a little bit
so I almost let I almost just left the
airport because I was like I don't want
to bug them
but I didn't I didn't leave and I only
took one picture I don't know what Eric
Eric's lip was trying to like operate
away or something
my wife would my wife is gonna be so mad
because she's like you always
family pictures you know you got kids in
the picture
guys Pro tip for you Pro tip when your
wife or your girlfriend your significant
other partner whatever ask you to take a
picture
always take more than one always every
single time you take more than one yo
there's Chandler Chandler in the chat
what's up Chandler thanks for being here
and hanging out dude yeah I would so I
was so glad we got to meet up and so I I
yeah I DM Channel like hey I got a
little early you guys want to meet up
real quick if you have time you know I
don't want to bother you or anything
I'm in La never been to this airport so
I didn't even think I could get over to
where they were but I was like what's
the worst that could happen I don't have
to get on another flight I had to take
this shuttle that like took me across
the airport and then so we met up we met
up we hung out for I don't know half an
hour or so
and I kid you not guys I kid you not
like it's all you know when you you
interact with people online that's one
thing but when you meet people in person
it's like a different ride
sometimes
so I'm like oh man you know is this
going to be awkward is there going to be
a lot of small talk no no I mean I felt
like I knew these guys I I hope they
felt the same way because that's that's
how I felt I mean there was no awkward
like small talkie conversation we were
just like we just hit an enemy of course
they they probably feel like they know
me better than I know them I mean
especially Eric Eric's very behind the
scenes right so Eric those who don't
know Eric's the one in the middle there
Chandler of course everybody knows him
so Eric marketing manager and then
Chandler the community manager so Eric's
a lot more behind the scenes Chandler a
little bit more forward-facing he's been
in the showcases and stuff
so they probably felt like they knew me
a lot better than I knew them but it was
dude I mean we just like we hit it off
we talked about we didn't just talk we
talked a little bit about Hogwarts
Legacy we talked about games in general
and just like the hype and and the
excitement of the fandom and just how
how crazy this ride has been so my trip
started off awesome you know got to meet
meet them hang out for a bit with those
guys and then the plan was to meet up
with uh
expecto go
Benjamin snow wizard tricks wizard PhD
and pink Ravenclaw
and I had told them I was like hey let's
meet up for dinner
so here's where the trip kind of takes a
little bit of a downturn a little bit of
a downturn here is because I got
introduced to LA traffic for the first
time
oh couldn't live there man could not
live there
could not live there LA traffic is
something different so all those all the
Hogwarts Legacy people they were waiting
on me for dinner they didn't say this
but I I'm pretty sure they were
so I'm texting James like dude I'm so
sorry you guys just go ahead and eat
don't wait for me please do not wait for
me go ahead and eat
so they go ahead and it takes me it
takes me over an hour to get like I
think it's like 13 miles 13 14 miles
over an hour oh I forgot this picture
though this is so cool so I'm on the
plane
look what this person was watching in
front of me you guys see it
take a picture of that I thought that
was so cool
I cracked up when I saw it it's like oh
I gotta take a picture this will be fun
this will be a fun picture right here
so yeah finally I get to the hotel I
don't even remember what time it was
when I got there and I wish I wish I had
gotten more
I I see why people have camera Crews
like I wish I could have documented this
whole freaking
night and a half basically I wish I
could have documented all of it
so finally got to meet up with James and
all those other creators which Let's see
we got some photos here
there's Benjamin snow
Benjamin snow very very tall
I guess I don't know I'm pretty close
pretty close but yeah Ben's pretty tall
Chandler's pretty tall as well
and then let's see here's Lynette
got to meet Lynette I thought we had a
group photo too
here's wizard tricks I didn't even know
wizard tricks before this trip so wizard
tricks has a really big Instagram this
man's got 100K followers on Instagram so
if you you are on Instagram check him
out he does a lot of Wizarding World
content and from what I understand from
James covered a lot of wizards unite as
well
and then let's see I think we got Rita
in here too yes there's Brita
pink Ravenclaw
got to meet up with her so this was all
like in the hotel that first night we
could I could have talked all night both
uh Brita and Lynette had early flights
the next day
so they didn't get to stick around too
long but uh it was just so awesome
meeting them so awesome meeting them
and then let's see
I didn't even get a picture with James
that night that was the first time James
and I met was that night
I think James has the one oh he sent it
to me but I don't have it in this folder
I'll have to pull it up later
I'll have to pull it up later you like
these pics Chris thank you thank you
yeah
all right so let's fast forward let's
get to the day that we get to go play
so we already talked about how James and
I went to the wrong uh we went to the
wrong side what's up nightly nerd
how tall is Ben and Chandler that's a
good question I don't know the exact
exact height
I'm not sure
yeah there's
all right let's see what else we got
what else we got here so yeah we go over
to the event
we finally find the right building
and we go in
and they took us up right away and so we
were at first there were a couple of
avalanche people in there we were
talking to a lot of the WB folks as well
which by the way I got a shout out I
mean everybody from I don't know if they
want their names they probably don't
want me broadcasting all their names
here Chandler and Eric they're a little
bit more forward-facing they don't care
but I I mean I just have to shout out
all of the uh the people who set all
this up like
from the people that just were emailing
us from WB I'm 510 nightly nerd I'm 510.
Chandler six two I was gonna I was gonna
guess six two yeah I was gonna say about
six two six three
close close
510 for Austin as well nice
yeah so all the people at WB though I
mean just the people who were emailing
us to set set all this up from the
people who we met the day of who helped
us get settled in there and helped ran
the session so I don't even know I don't
know if this part was intended but after
we finished up our gameplay we kind of
just I was like I'm just gonna stand
here and talk until they ask me to leave
like how long can we actually stay up
here could I like could I go again could
we go for another game
no I didn't ask for that but I was like
I'm just gonna hang out here and chat so
they're like hey we got lunch you guys
want to have lunch sure we'll have lunch
and then one of the highlights of my
trip
one of the highlights
this moment right here this moment right
here
getting to meet Boston and Allen so I
met
when we first got up there we went into
this room where we watched a little
presentation it was a video presentation
from Alan here
so Alan it was um a lot of if you've
been following the games the last stuff
we already knew but there was also some
new stuff too about like there I mean as
we've talked so much like about the
passion of the team and how excited they
are for this that really came through in
the video that they shared with us there
not like a ton of new gameplay footage
or anything it was mostly Alan talking
and sharing some stuff with us so that
was pretty cool I'd gotten to meet
Boston for a just like a split second
right before this
and I hadn't got to meet Alan yet so I
was like I was probably annoying them
because I was like is that is Alan here
I want to meet Alan I want to say hi to
Alan so Alan doesn't come in until we
start our gameplay session so we're in
there we're playing games and I see him
he's like so if I'm I'm like playing on
the monitor right here he's standing
behind the monitor
I just finished the combat section it
was like the crossed wands and I was I
was just like so into the combat I had
to I had to I hadn't even actually met
Alan yet I'm just like Alan the combat
I just gave him like this big thumbs up
big thumbs up I was like
I haven't even met you yet but I just
gotta I just gotta say the combat is so
good
so good
so we had our gameplay session
like I said James and I asked for the uh
for the performance mode so all our
footage in performance
so that was cool then after like meeting
all the people like all the creators and
all the different people I mean you guys
we met some of the people who are QA
testing the game again I don't know if
they want all their names out there and
stuff but you guys know who you are
all the people that we met from
Avalanche all the people that we met
from WB were just so so nice so
accommodating and hearing them talk
about
all the different aspects of the the
different parts of this game that they
worked on and stuff it was it was so fun
so like I said after we played the game
that's when I I had a chance to talk to
Alan and Boston even more because I was
like I got so many questions for you
guys I got so many questions and one of
the highlights is when Boston told me
she watches our Harry Potter Let's Plays
guys Boston watch
I was so I was like oh my gosh are you
serious because I the question I asked I
asked Alan I was like did you guys play
a lot of the old games
in preparation for this because for
those of you who watch our Let's Plays
here on the channel you know we just
played through um Goblet of Fire which
is a it's a rough one rough one to get
through
but in in the Goblet of Fire game they
have this meter it's called the magickus
extremus uh meter
so I was like I just gotta ask Alan is
that where the idea did you guys get the
idea from that and he actually said they
they did not play a lot of the game like
the old games to do a lot of research
that they wanted this to be kind of a
fresh take that stood on its own which
it totally is but then I think it also
has so many little things that kind of
hearken back to those old games which it
sounds like it was almost unintentional
which makes it even more I think even
more epic that it was like that
but yeah Boston said she watches the
Let's Plays she's been watching some of
them
we talked about midnight Harry Potter
releases going to midnight book releases
and let's see did we have uh we had a
couple of new subscribers come in thank
you guys for subscribing
Gleason with the five dollar Super Chat
sorry I missed that one let me let me
scroll back and make sure that I uh okay
Supernova and then Gleason what were the
rules we had to follow for the event did
you get sorted into us no so everybody
was Gryffindor worked out for me right
it's Marty Gryffindor everybody was
Gryffindor we did get to create our
character at the beginning how are you I
didn't want to spend a lot of time on
that because we've already seen it you
know I just wanted to get into the
gameplay
[Music]
so we uh created the character that was
you know right there at the start and we
didn't do any kind of sorting or
anything so it was we did get to pick
the uh the attire though so as you're
checking out all the other content
creators footage
at first I thought I saw James because
in inspector goes video he had like a
green cave I was like oh wait did he do
Slytherin but no it was just different
uh different clothing
we couldn't show the clothing menu we
weren't allowed to show the clothing
menu but they did let us pick at the
beginning there were all these different
clothing options we could pick from and
as you see like if you watch the if you
watch just my gameplay footage I don't
know how much of it is going to show in
the um
there's not a ton of it that shows in
the in the preview video I did but if
you go back and you watch the full
gameplay footage you'll see is like I'm
looting you just get random clothing
items along the way as you're going and
so full the game is full transmog they
the the gentleman who was helping me
from Avalanche we all had kind of like a
person who was assisting us make sure we
didn't go too far off the beaten path
but also just to kind of help us if we
ran into any trouble
and so the person who was helping me was
was really talking up the the ability to
like you can you can wear whatever you
want
and keep the stats you want so you know
in some games it's like you find this
piece of gear that has these awesome
stats on it
but it looks terrible you don't have to
worry about in this game you don't have
to worry about it you're gonna be able
to wear whatever you want even in
classes which
which
um
trying to decide how much of this I
could probably share so as you go
through the game like there may be times
when characters comment on the stuff
that you're wearing maybe but only
certain things but only certain things
so that's like one of those fun little
Easter eggs that'll be fun to uh
discover on your own I don't know I
don't know what it is I don't know what
like the clothing item is but we you
already see a little bit of this in the
footage that I shared today the preview
of the game so as I walk by that
Fountain and I even call it out and let
you guys hear the audio the Slytherin
makes a comment of there's the troll
Slayer of hugs
and I think there's gonna be more stuff
like that yeah I think there's gonna be
a lot more stuff like that so as far as
like the other rules go yeah we just we
did the Character Creator Gleason we did
a little bit of exploration around
Hogwarts we had to stay on the Hogwarts
grounds so we kind of got to fly around
a little bit I spent too much time
looking for secrets
I'd been told
won't mention any names but I've been
told that there were some there were
some secrets that I should try to find
you're a wizard oh yeah let's go I'm
gonna try to find these secrets so I
spent too much time looking for Secrets
I could there were a couple mini games
that I could have done outside the
castle I know expecto go got some of
this in his capture of when he's like
playing doing the accio on the little
board and the balls you like accio and
draw them forward
I didn't get any of that or a wizard I
didn't get any of that because I'm just
I'm just like flying around jumping in
the water doing all that stuff so yeah
Hogwarts grounds we had to stay on there
and then when we got into the castle
we had we had somewhat Freedom once we
got in the castle I got to go through
all of the library I got to go through
the hermology greenhouse and that little
fountain that Boston described as kind
of like the Grand Central Station of
Hogwarts that whole area that's where we
spent a lot of time
and
then when we when we got into the
mission it was basically just play the
mission yeah oh and then cross once we
had cross ones as well yep so as far as
like
um limitations yeah they had like those
areas where we they needed us to stay
and then on the footage really all they
said was like don't show the menus and
that was just because there was like
there's Dev stuff that sometimes pops up
in the menus like Dev code and that kind
of thing
yeah
all right let's see more subscribers
trickling in guys welcome thank you so
much Dr Sherman almost 900 holy cow okay
that's officially a record Dr sherbet
thank you for the Super Chat and then we
had Dylan gifting five tier one
memberships Dylan what is up dude Dylan
another moderator guys shout out to
Dylan always showing love and support
thank you very much Dylan and congrats
to the new members of house wrecking
tour
congrats to the new members enjoy your
emotes you get discount on merch if you
want merch and a special Discord role as
well feathers with the five months yo
feathers good to see you here
and then a couple more subscribers
coming in
and then L one with another Super Chat
oh my gosh Owen
too much love and support from elwin you
guys shout out to all the creators who
never forgot about us even while taking
this in this amazing experience we know
you tried so hard to get all our
questions answered cough PC line
gameplay call
good point for bringing that up Ellen
yeah to all the PC folks out there I did
ask
and Chandler if you're still watching I
don't know if that's something you guys
will be able to show at any point but I
did ask it's like are do you know if
there are any plans to show off like PC
controls beforehand and they they didn't
know that the people I was were talking
to you know they were they were helping
me out with the demo uh they did say
they know that they're obviously working
very hard on making sure that it's a
good experience but I really do I really
am curious I'm not gonna play it on with
mouse and keyboard but I am curious
because it seems like it's so well built
for the controller right so well built
for the controller
I mean we're we'll talk about combat
here in a second because I was
the combat
I was so impressed by I really was when
I stopped I'm not exaggerating when I
stopped in my gameplay and had to give
Alan a thumbs up on that
volte with a super chat there's that
murder I heard he killed someone wait
what is that
that's from three minutes ago volte
thank you for the Super Chat I don't
even remember what I uh
don't remember what that was in
reference to Draco Chandler said you
were very close was that close Chandler
oh my gosh I'm so mad I felt like I was
in the vicinity
I felt like I had to be in the vicinity
um
well there you go guys there's there's a
secret somewhere some a secret cave that
we're gonna have to find when the game
comes out
a secret thank you Draco for the Super
Chat appreciate it volte with another
Super Chat I hope the students say stuff
about us using AK I didn't think about
that so yeah when we when we have access
to crucio that is jumping
forward a lot further
in the game we don't know how much
further Oh I thought this was awesome
too so in our hotel I wish I'd I should
have gotten a video of this this was
actually the elevator
so the elevator when you got in that's
what it looked like so you can kind of
see there's like a thin line right there
that's where the elevator door opens I
wish I'd gotten video of that like
opening and closing
but thank you volte for the Super Chat I
mean I think
also there's an article that we need to
read at some point I think it's from
game rant
this morning this whole day's just been
so crazy but there was an article where
there I know Alan's been doing a lot of
interviews I saw him pop up on IGN
and a couple of other sites so there
might have been a lot of stuff in that
game rant interview that we need to get
caught up on later
pineapple cheers Productions with a
super chat hope you had fun did they
give any indication on if combat
difficulty would be based on AI changes
or damage changes
good question
I don't recall
they I will if you check the port key
game support website and also WB game
support on Twitter
they've been working overtime lately
they are answering I mean I've I've lost
count keeping up with all the questions
that they've been answering from people
on there about the game
but that's a good question I feel like I
have seen something about it but I don't
I don't want to speak on it pineapple
and get it wrong
I don't want to speak on it and get it
wrong I was playing on normal difficulty
and it just as far as like how it felt
it felt like a good a good challenge I
think we were at level 19 when we were
in that story Mission I think level 19
is what I remember so that kind of give
you an idea
of what it will be like uh Gleason with
another Super Chat as well I'm gonna be
playing on PS5 Gleason yeah PS5 and
that's that's what we were playing on at
the event that's what I have it
pre-order for as well
lowercase Logan in the house what's up
Logan good to see you here my friend
retro first of all you're awesome my
question how did the flying feel and I
thought we couldn't fly very high look
like you all went High I see I remember
Alan saying that lowercase Logan as well
I tried to go up pretty high because I
wanted to see if I could get footage of
the you remember the Boost meter the
little yellow meter and I'm pretty sure
it was the second gameplay showcase when
they showed off the flying they showed
like as you get really high that meter
will start to go down
I did go pretty high and I never got it
to happen so I don't know if I just like
maybe I could have went higher and
didn't know
but thank you for the Super Chat and
thank you for saying I'm awesome
appreciate that you guys are awesome you
guys are awesome but yeah we talked a
little about the flying how it felt
earlier so the way they I think they
want it to feel a little bit sluggish
it's not supposed to feel like you're on
this Fireball like in Harry's day plus
you're going to be able to upgrade it as
well so when you first hop on it which
actually lets uh
we can pull that back up
because I had a pretty good view of it
right here
so here you see you see that little
trail behind so right now I'm holding R2
that's when it felt the best to me
but when I let go of R2 right here
coming up right there you kind of just
getting like this little hover position
and you can still fly like that
and so when you're flying like that it's
kind of like it's more like a Scenic
kind of looking around type thing
but when you hold R2 and and we also
know you'll be able to upgrade your
broom be able to upgrade the broom as
well
all right let me get back to my pictures
here you guys are asking good questions
though yeah keep the questions coming
which by the way I realized we didn't
even
is this the Allen
they're multiple Allens so there's a
so here's Alan Johnson right here
Alan Johnson works for WB he was there
got a picture with him
shout out to Alan Alan's very cool James
already knew Alan from uh the Wizards
unite days then I got a chance to meet
Alan as well but I think that Allen
you're probably referring to is uh Alan
two so this is this is Alan two right
here
right here the game director
okay and then at the event so the other
thing at the event James did get a
picture of all or somebody got a picture
I don't even know who took this picture
who took this picture right here
I think it's one of the people for WB
okay shout out to Miranda lorians as
well
so I did not know the the session that
James and I went to there were there
were four of us there so the other one
pictured uh we didn't get a picture with
her but there was another person there
too Miranda we met on this trip for the
first time
we James and I were just having lunch
again we kind of stuck around
they didn't ask us to leave they said
hey you want some lunch so I said uh
sure yeah well
why not guys why not let's sit up here
and chat for a little bit longer
and then Miranda was one of the other
creators there so she saw James and I
talking she came over sat down we
started talking
and just kind of hit it off talking all
things Hogwarts and content creation
YouTube all that stuff
so we hung out for a bit and then
oh this was this was a cool part so they
had us
this was a surprise we didn't know about
this till
I found this out like the morning that I
was flying out
we found out that they had gotten us
tickets to The Wizarding World or to
Universal which has the Wizarding World
in it in LA
so but because I wasn't getting in until
a day later James had already used up
his ticket so James went with a wizard
PhD
Potter collector was there too shout out
to Peter I'm so mad I wanted to meet
Peter
Peter from The Potter collector you guys
been covering Harry Potter the World of
Harry Potter for so long on YouTube does
a phenomenal job on his channel I really
wanted to meet him I knew he was going
to be there wanted to meet him didn't
get a chance to meet him because he was
there the day before
but um so James had already used his
ticket to Universal and so would all the
others so I was like oh man I'm gonna
have to I mean I'll go to Universal by
myself I don't care I'll just I'll do
everything I'll Vlog you know that
single Rider line right
so then we meet up with Miranda at the
event it just so happens she she's like
are you guys going to Universal after
I was like actually I am so she and I
went to Universal James I think went
back to the hotel or he had a friend out
there that he hung out with for a while
so we went to Universal did a lot of
vlogging
eight of the three broomsticks had to
have a butter beer did that so if you
guys haven't seen Miranda's Channel she
does a lot of Let's Plays she just
Platinum God of War
so plays games like God of War Red Dead
obviously I think I think it's safe to
say she's gonna be playing Hogwarts as
well
so it was great to get to meet her hang
out for a while we do I do have a vlog
yes TG I do have a vlog
that is nowhere close to being ready
nowhere close to being ready but I do
have a vlog
Gleason with another Super Chat thank
you Gleason do you think you can
customize the hogsmeade shop
oh
and thank you for becoming a member as
well Gleason welcome to house rack and
tour
I don't know which are you talking about
the exclusive or the uh one year timed
exclusive PlayStation thing the haunted
hogsmead that one I could see being able
to yeah
we didn't see anything about that that's
just that's just a guess as far as other
hogsmeade shops go I don't know I don't
know
David was here with a super chat David
what's up dude so happy you got to
experience it all also do you think
we'll be able to sit down
okay David
I would really love to sit down on that
stool from the winter ASMR okay guys all
right all right
I asked about sitting
I asked about sitting and I I don't
think you're gonna be able to
I don't think we're gonna be able to we
definitely could not in any of the stuff
I saw
anybody from Avalanche WB is watching
and I'm wrong feel free to correct I
don't think we can I'm not gonna say I'm
100 sure because they didn't it wasn't
like a definitive no
but if you remember that fountain
actually let me just pull that back up
too
well you know what let me show you guys
uh
let's take a look at the new footage
I just want to make sure I don't pull up
something that I'm not supposed to show
yet hold on
um
okay so let me go into this folder right
here
so if you guys have seen I'm sure you
have seen a lot of the footage that's
been shown today
there is one little mini puzzle side
quest kind of thing
that we got to see
called moth to a frame
and we are allowed to show this this is
one of the things we're we're allowed to
show
and this was just like an example of
some of these kind of random
Field Guide pages and things like that
that you can stumble on when you're in
Hogwarts all right hopefully this is not
going to be too loud so it's only a
couple minutes long it's about three
minutes long no Major Spoilers or
anything unless you guys don't even want
to know about side quests or anything
but let's just go ahead and watch this
here
hello I don't believe we've met oh The
Voice a lot of a lot of people been
commenting on my character's voice
so I didn't spend a lot of time on the
voice when you first start the game you
get to customize your um
like your tone and your pitch there's a
little slider for it and right when I
got to that point they were like we need
we need to go to the next section so I
literally didn't even have a chance to
like listen to them I just pulled the
slider picked picked one and went with
it so some people have been saying my
character sounds a little bit like a
robot I didn't have time to tweak it did
not have time to tweak it so this is in
that little Fountain area so distracted
at the moment everyone thinks I'm
utterly balmy
Samantha thinks I'm potty but it's this
painting I never know so she had a
little icon if I know win over talk to
her empty frame doesn't appear for no
reason how can you have a library
there's something you can't sit in you
can sit on your broom can confirm that
so I'm just kind of showing the
difference any insights about the
dialogue options there I did discover
lumos has an effect of some kind
but I'm not sure what to do next
dude if I have the time I may look I
have to show you guys a picture of me
sometime like from back in the day
no beard this is
shockingly close intriguing shockingly
close my eight year old looked at it and
said oh my gosh that looks like is that
I know right I was trying to get it
pretty close
do come and find me if you stumble on
something so there we go we cast lumos
and as soon as we cast it says final
location depicted in the paintings a
spot must be a clue
I should look around in case it's nearby
and they were kind of guiding me through
this
because we were on a time crunch so they
obviously wanted us to spend our time so
I'm kind of looking at it like okay do I
recognize this you guys already know me
being not so great with directions you
already know
uh b-i-g-a thank you for the Super Chat
as well did you see the full map dude
I'm so mad at myself I didn't even think
to pull up the map but some people did
and even if I had pulled up we we
couldn't show the menus or anything
watch out it's the troll Slayer of hawks
me right there watch out it's the troll
Slayer of hogsmead
so they were kind of guiding me where to
go I didn't remember this you see that
other field guy page just flying on
vacation from the painting
what could be so special about it so my
first thought I was like oh maybe we're
supposed to accio this so I try accio
nothing it's just still sitting there
lumos then we try lumos
let's get you back to your starts flying
around the
wand
and I also wish
darn it dude I wish I'd went over there
too and looked at that door
[Music]
which by the way I want to point out
right here it's a moth
remember how when we first started
seeing footage people were saying that
oh there's not like young
like look this we got a really short
wizard right here then a taller one here
now another cool thing is I'm wondering
I don't know this is me like putting
back my speculation hat back on now
I don't know
if all the students are randomly
generated or what because I was seeing
someone else's footage today and the the
students sitting right here
they were wearing like quidditch robes
so I don't know if that's all randomly
generated or what I I don't know how
that works
I I don't know now the reason whole
reason I decided to pull this up this
Fountain right here to get back to
David's question about sitting down
there is a prompt that appears and a lot
of people thought oh that means you can
sit right there just like these other
students you're a wizard Harry in this
case no you could not I went over to it
it is an interact instead you interact
with the Statue right there so it was
not a sip problem
I dude you guys talking about everybody
wants to learn the dark arts look at
this Slytherin teach me everything going
in fact if heckett doesn't hurry up and
teach me the imperious curse I swear I
shall get on that train and go home
oh my goodness I knew that was a
connection I should tell them and then
right here you're a wizard this is one
of my favorite Parts dude the sound cues
the sound cues and the music
oh they've they've they've nailed it
listens listen this is that empty frame
right it's so good
and then we get another one when I
complete the quest up here it's like
slightly different
Lenora I solved the mystery of that
painting
watch this I did this one for you guys I
knew you all would enjoy this
I'm afraid I can't tell you Lenora
but then I couldn't stick with it I
should have stuck with it but I couldn't
do it
I'm only joking
we found the location depicted in the
painting and then I cast lumos to guide
a moth back to the frame all very
logical I suppose pity hours she seems
so used to solving it so upset you have
a knack for solving riddles Matty's good
at that too and then listen we've been
pronouncing Amit wrong everybody we've
been saying Amit
here's the correct pronunciation
so is a meat although he does tend to
over explain
well I'm glad someone figured it out
a meat a meat guys
you're a wizard Harry
so good the music is so good
so good also while we were there at the
event while we were up there playing
we um they had to Overture to the
unwritten playing in the background and
I think some other music too maybe that
we haven't heard yet
that that soundtrack is gonna be
gonna be a must-have
all right we'll let this play play again
in the background so you guys can watch
it through again
oh let's see we had
we answer big about the full map and
then we had Moon Lily where you shocked
when the animagus joined the fight yes I
was
before so shocked at that and do you
think we might get a side quest to
become an animagus
like my hunch says no again nothing they
said I didn't learn that's not anything
that's just a guess have you gained any
insights about it I don't think so but
they they keep wowing they keep
surprising they keep surprising
so it's clearly like I mean they have
the wolf animation built into the game
maybe maybe the time I may look my guess
would be no intriguing I wouldn't put
money on it
but it would be epic if they did
and then we had dally boy with a super
chat thank you my friend how's the flow
of speed running stopping and then
running again the animation whenever you
stopped kind of seemed very abrupt also
congrats hey Dolly boy thank you for the
congrats appreciate it
very much
so
I'm trying to think if I really had a
spot where I sprinted all that much
out I mean like right there all this
felt very good all of it felt very good
there was a time when I was on the beach
like the location
where oh man I'll have to see if I can
find that footage I was like kind of
near the water
on the little uh like kind of like the
shorelines get you back to your frame
and it felt like my Sprint like it
wasn't sprinting all the way
and I don't know I need to go back and
watch that and see if I can figure out
what was going on there because the rest
the rest of the time it felt fine so I
don't know if my controller was bugging
down or what but yeah I didn't uh I
thought I thought it felt good like
maneuvering the character I thought it
all felt really good like the moment
they put the control in my hand and I
first took control
the the immediate thing that jumped out
to me like first gut reaction was this
looks way better than anything they've
shown so far and I'm on performance mode
and it was also so smooth so smooth that
was my first like just looking then once
I started moving I was like oh this
feels good this feels good this feels
really good
so yeah
um I'm only joking
I will say the combat you can only cast
like when you cast your character will
stop
so unless I just wasn't president simply
right I don't think you can run around
and cast spells as they've described it
before it is kind of like this long
distance fencing which
feels so good
In the Heat of battle it feels so good
music one more time and see right there
collection updated
so look at this we just unlocked this uh
Cobalt regalia
right there
the I can't wait to see the stuff that
people
the attire that you unlock and all the
different combinations people come up
with
so in the other part the second part
when I'm actually doing the mission
that part we didn't get to pick our
it just kind of uh it was our same
character but all the stuff they had on
it just appeared I don't know why this
is not going like all the way full
screen
I'm not sure let's get the music going
again
um let's see CJ with a super chat as
well can't wait to see your let's play
PS4 gang here hey thank you CJ yes you
know you already know we're gonna be uh
playing it here on the channel we're
probably gonna be playing it live so
if you guys didn't know this about
YouTube now they have actually
um
they have separated out
so if you go to my home page right here
this is actually this is a good change
videos shorts and live are now all
separated
so if if you watch my regular videos
then you'll you know you'll see anytime
I post a regular video but if you don't
watch a lot of the lives then you
probably wouldn't even see some of the
stuff so you have to actually like click
into the live and then you can see all
the live streams we've been doing
right there
now if I go to home let's see I do think
I have a little uh
oh I have like a past live streams but I
need to move that up so I can control
this I'll move that up but yeah thank
you for your support glad you enjoyed
the uh glad you enjoyed the videos
all right I'm gonna pull this one up now
too so this is the uh
so this is the story mission that we got
to see
so if you don't want to see I'm gonna
have it muted so if you don't want to
know about any of the dialogue you know
just uh
you just don't have to look at the at
the words or anything
I don't personally think it spoils too
much but I've already heard from some
people who are like I'm I'm tap I don't
want to see any of it
so I'll keep it on mute that way you
don't hear it but this is a pretty cool
this so this is what I was talking about
like see my character's wearing blue
gloves here then we got the little hat
and then the the scarf is different to
still Gryffindor and still my the
character model that I picked though
yeah
and then SS Vita with the Super Chat yo
thank you SS Vita appreciate it
appreciate it how far does the
relationship system go
we didn't get to see anything anything
about like relationships and how that
system would work
like this quest with poppy was really
extent of it we did have the choice in
the uh crossed wands dueling area
we got to pick if we won a natsai or
Sebastian as a as a uh
oh what do you call it like the duo
partner companion
companion if we will
I'm trying to think if there was
anything else like that the Hufflepuff
student Lenora she like talks about
other
students but we didn't know yeah we
didn't really see like how the
relationship system works and if it like
builds if you
do more activities with the character or
not we didn't get really didn't get to
see anything on that
thank you for all the new Subs guys
welcome welcome
you're a wizard did you get to see the
common rooms no I think they're safe
well we've seen all the common room
tours I guess in the videos they've
released but I think they don't want to
spoil that
they want you to have that experience
yourself for the first time
oh but yeah man
Gleason what's up need help in the
Discord uh exclamation point Discord
will get you to it if you need help like
actually in the Discord a lot of the
mods are probably here right now so
they're they're probably not gonna be
able to help out much but I'm sure one
of them will be able to help after the
Stream
so unrated the attire for us in this
section was random but it is not random
in the game you get to you get to set
that
you're a wizard Harry you get to set it
yourself
it's like make sure this is the 4K I'm
telling you guys I'm telling you YouTube
doesn't do it justice the YouTube
compression and here's another talking
about little technical quirks watch this
one right here and again I think this is
just like not being the final version
because everything I mean it was running
very smooth but watch this like my
character it's gonna jerk over
here I'll watch it just like letting it
play
right there it's almost like it like I
stepped on something in the world or
there was an area there that I wasn't
supposed to and it just kind of pulled
me over
hahaha
oh it won't give you the roll okay you
might have to um
you have to make sure your YouTube and
Discord are linked and then it might I
don't know it might take like a refresh
period
I don't know
I don't know how long that uh
how long it takes
Elwyn I think Gleason's talking about
the special role the prefect role for
channel members is my is my guess
does our character have a name good one
good question you get to name your
character
you get to name your character that is
on the character select screen it's like
one of the very first things you do
yep when you make your character you'll
get to name them so I chose retro reckon
tour for my name and you can actually
like you'll see it if you have subtitles
on
you'll see it down there at the bottom
potion consumption
so the only potion I use Moon Lily the
only potion I used was wig and weld
that one is mapped to
I'm pretty sure where's my PlayStation
controller
I'm pretty sure it was down on the d-pad
and it was like instant in battle it's
very very quick
the other potions that they're gonna put
on L1 I didn't use any of those I don't
even know if I had any
I guess I should have looked
the thing about the combat guys I can't
stress enough how
like frantic is the word I keep coming
back to but I mean that in a positive
way like usually frantic you might think
of that as a bad thing I mean that in a
positive way all the footage that we
have seen Chandler talked about he said
it in the Reddit post where he explained
like guys I'm it's like I'm telling you
Andrew's really good at the game
he's really good at this game so all the
footage like the gameplay showcase stuff
the trailers like we're seeing the best
combat can look now today
you guys are gonna get to see some of
the stuff where it doesn't look so great
so this was one thing I was like it was
kind of disappointing I was hoping you'd
be able to use accio to pick these up so
like I tried on the little leech right
there
and it didn't work so I just had to push
square and then I tried it on the uh so
I don't know maybe that's something
you'll be able to unlock later but my
guess is you're just gonna have to walk
up and pick them up so there's probably
only certain things that accio will
interact with
or maybe I needed to I don't think you
could lock onto objects like that though
I don't think so
and then uh or division with the Super
Chat what is up or division fellow
Hogwarts Place Legacy creator
if you haven't checked them out check
out his videos see if see if enjoy them
if you do consider subscribing or
division thank you for the support my
friend you should you should have seen
my jaw body and mind completely drop
while watching you today on my life oh
did you watch it live
that's great live reaction to it oh
that's great amazing robes and facial
expressions were weird but game is fire
yeah somebody was asking about the
facial expressions on Twitter and like
the mocap
I think
I think it looks better than what we had
seen I feel like it's about
it's about 90 there 90 there I feel like
and again even if that was as far as it
ever made it
I'm still gonna I'm still
this game man I'm telling you I saw
somebody in the chat asking like biggest
concerns so we talked about that in the
video
like at this point at this point let's
think about this hold on I'm gonna take
a bite of a cookie you're a wizard Harry
take a bite of a cookie here chat grab
it grab a snack settle in settle in
there's another um item right there you
see lavender patch scarf it said
foreign
my biggest thing
as I feel like it should be
with most people for any game
is how does it actually feel
do you guys like if for those of you who
are here last night we teased this last
night on our stream
Johnny that is
I completely forgot about that Johnny
they talked about that in the Autodesk
though you're right
you're right they had to get creative
and do it totally different than they
normally normally do for the mocap
because of the uh
the whole thing that happened in 2020.
Chris so stoked to be here with everyone
thanks mods for all you do in retro for
literally everything all the bugs and
issues seem so minor to me hyped hashtag
hyped yeah yeah so back to the question
though yeah Chris's comment kind of gets
at that
so for me I when I was uh Luke Stevens
asked me to be on
and we had kind of a conversation about
hype and expectations and why I was so
excited for this game he asked me about
my hype level
and I said nine out of ten that was
before
that video if anybody's seen that video
that was all done before this this was
just this just literally last week when
we got to play and I said nine out of
ten
the only reason I didn't say 10 out of
10 is I was like because until you get
the controller
until you get it in your hands and you
actually play the game for yourself
it can look like the greatest thing in
the world
but until you play it now that I've
played it
I'm at a 10 out of 10. I'm at a 10 out
of 10. even with
even with the issues that we pointed out
I'm trying to think so the videos
seem like
it seemed like a lot of the creators
pointed out almost exactly the same
issues
believe it or not
almost exactly the same which is I mean
if you're Avalanche like that's kind of
a I feel like that's a good thing
because if you want to like prioritize
oh we're going to work on this or that
or oh the sorry you're that's not
happening that's not going to be fixed I
mean basically at this point whatever
they're not working on right now it's
not gonna make it but
seeing this feedback now it could very
well make it into patches you know those
first couple weeks
but I'm I'm like totally ignorant to
game development I don't I don't know
how long stuff takes I guarantee it all
takes much longer than we we think
that's for sure
but um
but when I got the controller in my
hands I just I can't stress enough man
like
I knew I knew right away I knew right
away just from the way the character
moved just from the frame rate that it
moved how smooth it was and then when I
started casting spells
I was like yep yep it's that feel it's
just that feel that you you can't you
can't judge you can't say until you play
it for yourself
and that that was the moment I had that
was the moment I had and I was like yep
all the concerns
hopefully they can be fixed but I'll
enjoy that I'll enjoy this game even if
literally every concert we pointed out
I'll still enjoy the game now just
because I'm saying my hype is at a 10
out of 10 now that's not I'm not saying
it's gonna be like a perfect game no
game's perfect
no no no game is perfect there are some
that come close but no game is perfect
oh
I want to talk about this spot right
here because
here's another thing that I think is so
amazing about watching all the different
creators footage from today is just how
different we like I learned something
new something different that I didn't
pick up on or something that I didn't
see in just about every person's video
that's Testament to create the creators
first of all I think the majority of
people covering this game have done a
spectacular job with the videos today
they've been awesome I've really enjoyed
watching them
um
but it's also a testament to Avalanche
and a testament to this game that we
talked about
and pointed out such such different
things
and in this I was talking to Ben
afterwards Benjamin snow and he kept
talking about repairing a bridge
and I was like what is he talking about
I never got a chance to repair a bridge
don't know what he's talking about
in his footage and I'm pretty sure
Professor Lynette was her phds as well
they did something maybe it was a barrel
or something they did something that
destroyed this bridge
destroyed it it never happened to me
never happened so all I did in this
section
I wanted to try out stealth so I did
stealth on literally every enemy
which it's it's Square petrificus
totalus boom he locks up Falls over
I did it on every enemy except the last
one so poppy does the same thing she
goes into the
disillusionment as well
and then this one I wanted to test I was
like okay nobody's been alerted yet how
close to this dude can I get so he was
looking right at me so he sees this guy
fall over I've heard Centos quieter than
you he shouts poacher Ranger but then I
sort of Dash away and I don't think he's
I still don't think he sees me
but then he did kind of turn my
no he's now he's just panicking and then
I have the ancient magic I'm like all
right I'm not even dealing with this guy
just ancient magic lightning bolts on
him
he's gone
and my bridge isn't destroyed
did I see what happened to Miranda right
there no
I saw uh I know in Wizard tricks is me
wizard tricks has one of the best clips
of this spot right here he just gets
launched
he just gets straight up launched
in this little section right here he
starts fighting these guys I don't know
if he got discovered or what but he
starts fighting these guys just gets
absolutely launched off the cliff right
there
watched all the cliff
oh my goodness but I did I haven't
watched all Miranda's footage yet I
haven't watched it
what happened what happened in hers
all right so we answer moonly using
potions in combat smooth yet so I only
use the Wigan Weld and it was just like
it was instant it was instant I don't
know about the others because I didn't
get a chance to do those Christy what's
up Christy here as well another fellow
moderator thank you Christy for hanging
out good to see you congratulations on
getting to play meet everyone definitely
deserve it but you sneaky
I mean unbreakable vows Christy they're
very you know you gotta keep your
unbreakable vows
but thank you Christy for the Super Chat
and thank you for all you do on the
moderator team as well
SS Vita oh that's a good question I
don't know the answer but I think I have
an idea for you
SS Vita asks do you know anything about
the collector's edition coming out again
no I don't like zero inside information
haven't heard anything here's what I
will say from my experience with
the God of War collectors edition right
here
the hammer was included in that one
that's pretty awesome
um in in past with past games a lot of
times
like the week of launch even the day of
launch the day after you will see stock
start to come in
people think it's new I just think it's
like either people don't pick it up or
they decide to cancel it like Amazon for
example I didn't know if Amazon ever
put them up I have no idea but I think
they did but they just went out really
quickly
but usually they'll start getting some
stock that opens back up whether from
people canceling or whatever
and then uh Jake with another Super Chat
hi retro hi Jake how's it going
good to see you good to see you
thank you guys for the Super Chat it's
very much appreciated
Amazon gets a lot of restock Gabe said
yeah you usually see that happen Nathan
how did you guys capture the footage so
oh this was awesome shout out to WB for
this so
we didn't have to bring anything they
had
so the plate that we had the PS5 we had
the computer monitor and then we had
this Elgato
4K 60
I should have looked I think James
looked at exactly which one it was
and you just popped the SD card in you
hit the little button to start recording
and that was it it was awesome then they
gave us the SD card
actually you're a wizard here it is
right here here it is dude you want to
know how like
preciously I treated this thing through
the airport and
on my way back
it's like oh my gosh
I'm gonna put this I feel like I feel
like I should put this in a more secure
place than just my pocket
you're a wizard Harry
um
but yeah so it was it was a very nice
very nice setup
Cloud Roth 216 with the 25 Super Chat
Cloud Rock what is up thank you so much
for your support of the stream with the
Super Chat there do you think we'll be
able to use all the unforgivable curses
but still make the Light Side choices
when it matters congrats on getting to
play
thank you for the congrats appreciate it
it's all it's it's a dream come true man
wouldn't have happened without people
like you either would not have happened
oh okay so I feel like I need to say
this before every question now so we did
we didn't see anything about this there
was nothing that would give me any
indication
but let me think
so we did have we had crucio in this in
this section here but we're like level
19 or something
so here's the question again if you guys
miss it do you think we'll be able to
use all of the unforgivable curses but
still make the Light Side choices when
it matters I think so Cloud Roth I'm
gonna say yes and I think that's what
they mean by when they say there's no
morality system
I think they know that an awful lot of
people want to use AKA crucio and
imperio
and still try to be a Good Witch and
Wizard you know
I think they know that so I don't think
they're gonna have it like oh you just
cast crucio you're locked into the dark
path I don't think so I think that's
what they mean when they say they have
no morality system there's nothing that
like tracks it I think what really
determines the sort of path however many
there are which we don't know if it's if
it's two endings if it's like three
endings five innings if there's
different ways that different stories
can like like can Sebastian's questline
end
what is this music
get Sebastian's questline in in two
different ways
three different ways we don't know but
if it can I feel like it will be tied to
the
like the dot like there will be a
dialogue choice or or a point you come
to in the story where you decide
that's my guess
but it's just it is just a guess Sharon
good night thank you for being here
Sharon
let's see what did uh
foreign
not very Mr Moe other than
so that's also a good topic too
because I feel like people are kind of
handling this differently
we've always been very overly cautious
on spoilers here
and I mean we still are
um our our kind of motto that the mods
we've talked about is we've just said
unless it comes officially from
Avalanche then we're considering it a
spoiler so like art book stuff
it's official but it wasn't released in
an official way that Avalanche wants so
we like don't discuss it trophy leak
same thing yeah it's official but we're
not going to discuss it on stream
this one's like in this little bit of a
gray area where it's not directly from
Avalanche but I mean we did we got all
the footage from Avalanche this is what
they provided to us so I guess yeah it
is kind of official
however
and I was actually talking to some some
of the folks at Avalanche about this
um I was talking to them about
what dealing with like spoilers and
because fans have so many different
expectations and and as a marketing team
like it's a challenge right they have to
decide every trailer they put out you
guys they have to sit and look at like
is that too much do we want to save that
should we not include that should we
include this do people need to see more
of that
so that I all I can tell you is they're
always thinking about that so everything
you see is stuff that they have decided
is
they feel comfortable showing
me personally like I don't feel like
this the footage that I have has any
Major Spoilers
are their story reveals yeah yeah there
are like what you're seeing right now
this over here we got it on mute just in
case people don't wanna
know anything about it but it is it is
one of the game's story missions which
you know there are rumors floating
around about how long the game is
but I
I don't think it's a major spoiler but
if you know only you can decide like
what's a major spoiler for you I was
talking to uh Dustin one of our one of
our loyal members here who
um got spoiled earlier today and saw
something they didn't want to see and
and Dustin was just last night telling
us like I'm out for a while I don't want
to know anything else and then got
spoiled today by this footage which is
something that Dustin just didn't want
to see I don't even know what it was
actually but
so yeah everybody has a different level
like if if you if if you know your
spoiler level and you feel like hey see
in a story mission
which is not I don't think it's like the
game's uh you're a wizard name plot it's
not like the end or anything but if
you're like I don't even want to know a
single Story Mission then then yeah I
mean it's probably uh
probably time to to go dark on videos
you watch related to it and that kind of
thing
but also I think you gotta trust and
that's why I brought up the
conversations I had with some of the
folks that Avalanche I mean I think you
just have to trust that and and the
folks at WB like they they know they
know
the the Harry Potter IP has been under
WB for a long time they they know the
fans very well so everything they
release is very strategic and they it's
chosen deliberately so
yeah hope hope that hope that clarifies
a little bit for you zutara Bay what is
up zutara welcome thank you for the
Super Chat
I have a dumb question no no dumb
questions zutara you said you played
this in performance mode what does that
mean also so happy for you to
experiences for saying congratulations a
thank you zutara thank you for all your
support over the over these past few
months very much appreciated but no
that's not a dumb question at all that's
a that's a console thing it's console
lingo for people who um
are very familiar with consoles so
basically
what a lot of game companies have
started doing
is they give players the option this is
only on Console because PC it's just
PC have always had these controls so if
you have a PC you already know that when
PC games come out you basically can
control you can control things like
Shadows draw distance like you have
little sliders for all these settings
and you tailor it to your your computer
system and what it can handle consoles
have never had that they're like kind of
a one size fits all
and that's it's like a blessing and a
curse right it's what makes them great
because they're really easy to develop
for and all that sort of thing but it
also you know everybody gets kind of the
same experience well
as games and these con as the consoles
have gotten more powerful it really
started when
Microsoft and Sony did like the PS4 Pro
and the Xbox One X
because for years console makers were
all like they want we'll just make the
game look as good as we can
and then we'll have a low frame rate
because for many years console Gamers
were fine with 30
frame games at 30 FPS
in recent years though they've started
to realize that players want better
frame rates and so if you don't if you
aren't familiar with the frame rate and
that sort of thing it's just like a
smoother experience so when people say
games run at 60 FPS that's a relatively
smooth experience
if the game runs at 30 FPS it's kind of
like especially if you're really used to
PC and like higher frame rate games and
you go to 30 FPS it's almost jarring
it's jarring because it almost looks
like it's it's stuttering or something
so there's a really long answer to say
that performance prioritizes frame rate
whereas the Fidelity modes that's the
other mode Hogwarts Legacy will have
Fidelity mode prioritizes the image
quality
so if you want it to absolutely look as
good as it possibly can you'll choose
Fidelity if you want the best possible
frame rate you'll want to choose the
performance mode instead
that's that's the breakdown
me personally
I couldn't I thought it looked great in
the performance mode all my stuff was
performance mode
I know expecto goes was in performance
mode I think a lot of the others were in
the Fidelity mode
and when it comes out probably not a
breakdown on this channel but they're
very technical channels that break this
kind of stuff down because there are
trade-offs to each one
their trade-offs to each one so you like
you can compare and see like oh wow I
don't feel like the visuals are all that
different in performance mode so I'm
gonna go in performance mode or you may
say like geez if
I don't even care about frame rate it
doesn't bother me at all I want the best
picture so you can go with the the
Fidelity mode
but yeah not a dumb question at all good
question and thank you for thank you for
your support
pineapple cheers with another Super Chat
totally agree the day night cycle will
likely be narrative based and that's
okay I think they should rip the
Band-Aid off if so some are expecting
Skyrim like days
I don't I mean I feel like they've kind
of already said
in one of the showcases it was where um
oh gosh Alan was saying something of
like how
I guess people were asking about classes
too like are we just gonna be able to go
to class every day how does that work
and Alan said it's all it's narrative
based it's like based on the story so
you may have like you go to this class
to kind of kick off with that Professor
it's like a one-time thing you get a cut
scene and then you don't have to you
don't have to go and do that every
single day
then you can do like other little things
like like the little mini game like the
the mini game where you have the the
ball that we've seen in some people's
footage stuff like that
so I mean maybe if they wanted to be a
little bit more clear about it like
exactly how this is how you transition
which that's why I so if uh
was your PhD ever I'll ask was your PhD
after this stream
Alex exactly exactly yeah wizard PhD was
one of them and there was there was
somebody else too
they got to see night but I don't know
how they did it
it'd be really interesting if it just
kind of happened automatically
I want to raise a baby dragon oh I hope
so moonly I hope so
we didn't get to see any room of
requirement stuff
or like the vivarium stuff
I didn't get to see any of that
oh maybe pineapple Maybe
but yeah somebody earlier was asking so
like biggest concerns now
based off what we've seen so we pointed
out like the technical stuff
that who knows maybe some of it'll be
fixed maybe some of it won't I can tell
you if literally all of it is still
present in the final game I will still
enjoy the game
then the question becomes
how is the game as a whole right so
we've seen a couple of different
vertical slices now some specific
sections that they wanted us to see
then what is it like when it all comes
together what's the story like
how does that how do all the different
story lines interweave together
are the how's the mission variety so
this Mission the mission that we have
with poppy
similar structure to a lot of games you
see have this first little kind of
cutscene where they talk kind of
describe what's going on
then they have a
um kind of like this little
investigative investigative I think
that's how you say that word
investigative
section where you're having to use
revelia which by the way revelio guys
you're gonna you're gonna use that a lot
it's like um remember in the Batman
Arkham game so it has like the special
Vision Vision same thing for Joel and
the last of us this is like one that
actually makes sense within the within
the world right revelio you can be using
that a lot a lot because you can see
enemies you can see like the treasure
I don't know if you I mean we had access
to it in this so I don't know how early
you'll unlock it in the actual game but
revelio dude it's gonna be your bread
and butter it's gonna be your bread and
butter gonna use that a lot you can see
that I am
if you watch this this video I have
pulled up right now
I was constantly casting revelio when we
get down there where the dragons are I'm
just like revelio revealing I don't want
to miss anything
and it also helps you kind of plan out
your stealth if you're gonna try to play
stealth instead of going in like crazy
gotta have a photo mode Dr sherbet I I
had like a list of questions that I
wanted to ask that was one of them and I
just didn't get to it I didn't get
around to it our conversation started
leading Us in so many different
directions with all of the uh the folks
that we got a chance to talk to
afterward
that was one that I was I was mad at
myself for not asking but I don't know
if they could have answered it anyway
the good thing about photo modes though
guys is a lot of times you'll see them
at it after the game comes out like I
know God of War did that
God of War just did that and games do
that all the time
here's what I'll here's what I'll say
they they're listening
they're listening you guys
they are absolutely listening so
I guarantee they they've listened to all
the concerns that creators brought up in
the videos they've listened to all the
things that we were excited about
so they hear us and I feel like Photo
mode is one of those things that
again I'm ignorant on game development I
don't want to say how hard or easy it is
it could be very incredibly difficult to
do
could be really difficult to do but to
me is like someone on the outside it's
like oh you know that should be
that should be something
should be something
that you can uh add in Fairly easily
later on
that might be a good question to ask
though at some point if I ever get a
chance to meet or talk with any of them
again I'd love to ask that I'd love to
ask like how how difficult is it to
implement something like a photo mode
which it really is kind of becoming like
a standard in-game like I feel people
it's almost just something people expect
now in the really good like AAA games
it's like like God of War if they didn't
add that in oh my goodness people would
have been so upset if they didn't add
that in
I don't know why tonight like my whole
like this little
whatever whatever
don't know why it's staying up there
Chris with a super chat thank you Chris
for your support swimming confirmed
makes me think water Beast uh yeah
you're a wizard Harry don't I mean I
don't know if you guys want to be
spoiled on that but um yeah
I think so
or a wizard Harry
how many how many is the question
here I'm gonna turn sound on for a
second this guy this got some people
you're a wizard Harry all right if you
don't want to know creatures put your
earmuffs on for a second
put your earmuffs on for just a second
but this this jump scare got some people
you're a wizard Harry
here we go
that's the third time I've seen a dug
bug behave that violently
it seems to be more aggressive than
usual lately
I've noticed that too it's almost like
there's something in the water I know
right Poppy
all right
so remember guys like a few weeks ago on
stream when we were looking at the
second gameplay showcase and you guys
are like there's a red marker in the
water
there's a red marker in the water
dug Boggs dude Doug bugs
Russian now that we know we could swim
if you can get attacked by those things
I didn't I didn't see if you could cast
a spell while you're in the water but I
know you can you can uh get on and off
the broom in water like you could be
flying hop off the broom land in the
water and then you can like kind of pop
up out of the water right back onto the
broom
you totally missed it Chris
uh yeah it's uh shout out to the person
who was uh
assisting me with my gameplay because
they were like they sort of prompted me
they said uh take a look at this sweet
little deer over here
because I I was just looking all around
you guys noticed I was I was just
spinning the camera
I was trying to get as much as I
possibly could show off as many
different sections of the game
had that little moment at the beginning
with the centaurs there
but yeah then this right here so they're
like yeah just look at this little uh
Little Deer over here it's like Oh okay
that's cool why do you want me to look
over there and then I heard the music
say what
I know Dylan should I have should I have
tried to jump in and swim right there
oh somebody was asking about the uh why
did it say
why did it say Don't Turn back or
something
why does why does the game say turn back
at the start
good question Okay so
where does it happen right
so the way this session was set up we
had headphones but they were also trying
to talk to us at the same time
so I had my I was doing like this number
with my headphones so I had one side on
and the other side I was I had off
listening to them and then James was
right behind me James was sitting
directly behind me so I would hear him
react to something cool and so I'm
turning around like what are you looking
at dude what are you seeing right now
right
um so I had my headphones kind of like
this
oh no OBS disconnected hold up hold up
are we still here an entire Castle oh no
oh no hold on
hold on
I'm a little I'm a little scared
my computer just said OBS disconnected
hopefully we're still here okay good
everybody's still here whoo
whoo 787 viewers could you imagine the
stream dying could you imagine
I've never seen that message in my life
it said OBS Disconnected by the way hold
on we had we had some super chats super
chats come in here Dawes 19 with the
Super Chat thank you so much dude I got
a question is the lock-on system
automatic or manual really excited for
the game so it's uh it's R3
R3 so you can kind of look if you ever
see me actually I think I do it right
here
I think it's right before this where we
get to the centaurs
if you hold L2 it's kind of like a uh
I'm pretty sure it's right up here right
when we get up here
fully
right there so that I'm holding L2 kind
of Zooms in a little bit so it gives you
like a little bit of a of an aim there
wait hold on hold on
oh that was Dawes okay
I was like wait did I read the right
yeah is the lock-on system automatic or
manual yeah yeah so it's R3 when you're
when you're in battle it's it's R3 so
one day here
but that little that's L2 is just like a
little bit of a zoom and I have some or
some more footage I'm trying to remember
if it made it into my preview we have so
much footage you guys so much there's
there's so much stuff I'm still gonna be
able to release and show over the next
few days and weeks
so much
but um I was trying to when I was in the
library I was testing out that little L2
I was like so is this is this L2 purely
for zooming in and looking around
I think it is because I was trying to
use it to like aim at a field guide page
which now that you bring it up the lock
on only I don't think I could walk on to
a field guide page I'm pretty sure you
could only lock on to enemies when
you're fighting in the battlefield
because the um
yeah I'll have to double check on that
I will have to double check on that MX
but I'm almost positive that with the
field guide Pages it was almost just
like a general aim kind of like not an
auto lock-on but like I just had to sort
of have it in the center of my view
and then do accio and it would do it was
I didn't log it definitely didn't lock
on for those when you're in battle
though it's R3 like you click R3 in
that's how you lock on you can kind of
switch between like that and then we had
um AJ draws AJ draws what is up my
friend shout out to AJ draws an
incredible artist
still my Twitter picture is a from a
very awesome illustration that AJ draws
did featuring a lot of uh Wizarding
World creators still one of my favorite
things AJ said just want to thank you
for always being so upbeat retro love
all your HP all you HP content creators
appreciate the work you put into keeping
us hype and entertained AJ thank you
dude thank you for all you do
ajoma thank you for all you do as well
AJ draws
but yeah man this whole Community like
like uh James was saying today on his
stream guys this is a place where it's
it's okay to be hyped it's okay to be
excited
you know
I understand people want to talk about
cyberpunk and how you
you've been burned by games in the past
sometimes but you know what
it's okay it's okay and if this came out
and was terrible then
we still we still made a lot of good
memories right
still made a lot of good memories and
had fun along the way and thank you to
the new Subs coming in there as well
we're keeping Hagrid very busy tonight
guys very very busy
fall damage
I never got any fall damage I know you
can fall to your death though I know you
can fall to your death
I should have thought to do it but I
never did there's a lot of beasts have
been more aggressive than usual lately I
know wizard PhD did
so you can see what it looks like just
jumping off and falling to your death
yes yes yes we have a Discord
there you go Dylan's on it
thank you Dylan
wait hold on is nightbot taking the
night off
there you go nightbot you better show up
wizard PhD said there is fall damage
there you go thank you feathers thank
you
what what is it
yep good to know good to know
and good question too good question what
do NPCs refer to you as
uh Trace yes order Merlin merch so I
think that is a command as well
summation Point merch
let's see
or maybe it's yes it is good it's it's
it's awesome when technology actually
works the way it's supposed to yeah all
all the stuff we've ever put out is
still available on the merch on the
merch store and if you're a member make
sure you get uh get the discount you can
go to our community page on YouTube if
you're a channel member you get a
discount on the merch so yeah then the
other question was
welcome to Gryffindor
oh where did it go
what do NPCs refer to you as
I I don't think it was anything specific
other than that section where they we
heard the one say the troll Slayer of
hogsmeade
but yeah I I never heard any of them say
like a special name or anything just
just like generic you and
stuff like that yeah Joe Machado in the
house Joe Mack what is up my friend
becoming a member of House racket tour
we got to get out the hammer Joe we got
to get out the hammer and officially
welcome you my friend
you guys if you don't know Joe
I guarantee you've seen one of his
Hogwarts Legacy memes guarantee
thank you Joe good to see you here
did I did we see anything after this
poppy Quest no that was the last thing
and then we all cried because we had to
quit playing
I'm not exaggerating man fast
two hours of my life
fastest two hours of my life
it's like you're joking right that has
not been two hours
it's been like 30 minutes maybe oh right
here but here was the question somebody
asked why does it say return because
Poppy got too far away from me
this is when I was I mentioned how we
were set up so I had my headphones like
this
so I was talking to the guy from
Avalanche who was assisting me with the
demo then James is behind me so I'm like
you know James is going to get excited
I'm hearing James behind me
so I'm hearing all this other stuff
around me and so I was I actually think
it was the guy from Avalanche I was
talking to I don't know and if you get
too far away from her you'll get like
this little uh
we'll get this pop-up right here that
says return to the quest area which
feels a little bit tight to me like that
feels a little bit tight I don't know if
it needed to pop up that quick like why
couldn't I have just stood there for a
while and waited so it would count down
I don't know what would happen if I let
it go all the way down maybe it resets
the quest but as you see me quickly
start moving forward then I get close
enough and it goes back to normal yeah
yeah I think so modern gamer I think so
vrr yes Jonathan VR has been confirmed
on uh both PS5 and Xbox series s and X
yes yes yes it has
possible to save yourself using a Resto
momentum good question dogs good
question we didn't have access to that
spell right here we did not have access
to it but that is a great question
the ultimate game Boss gravity right
wondering if we go to the Hogwarts uh
like the rooftops
I tried and I know Lynette tried in her
footage too so they said there will be
areas you can you can land on I think it
was just either turned off for this or I
I couldn't I didn't find the correct
spot I guess because I tried I was
looking all around
to see if uh see if we could
imagine how fast time will feel post
launch I know
but then we get to start begging them
for like DLC and sequels
well first it's like okay I feel like
first thing we beg for is like any we
want anything fixed hopefully it comes
out dude I cracked up at this part back
to the question about the morality
system stuff like this are the reason I
think there's no morality system
there's I mean there's a little bit of
suspension of disbelief that you're
gonna have to do here it's kind of like
Nathan Drake right I mean the guy's
really a mass murderer but he comes off
as this you know Indiana Jones Action
Hero Nathan Drake
I think we're gonna have to suspend our
our uh suspend belief a little bit
because stuff like this is gonna happen
and the dude
falls off
he's just gone
and I I tell the guy I'm like what no
I'm trying to play as a light wizard
trying to play on the side of the good
yeah what no we can't have this you're a
wizard and he kind of just laughed like
well
good luck is basically the the reaction
I got
and then the other thing is the enemies
they do kind of uh
I don't think you get to see it right
here but they just they vanish after a
while so the bodies don't stay which I
actually I think that's a rated T for
teams this guy I was checking I was like
okay good he's still alive but then see
I should have I should have kept the
camera over there he kind of just Fades
away I actually think that's a ESRB
thing
I'm almost positive like if you leave
bodies sounds awful to say like if the
body stayed laying I think that starts
to push the game into m m territory
at least in the US I don't know how it
is in other other countries but I'm
pretty sure I'm right out so there you
go you get a nice reveillo and then the
the yellow is going to highlight your
any uh treasure and then the red of
course is highlighting enemies CAD Bane
Bounty Hunter with a super chat thank
you my friend if she gets too far away
why would she stop yeah she should come
back
they stop in a lot of other games I
thought or am I wrong yeah no you're
right they do and and this was like
maybe this this was a special thing for
our build
I don't know I don't know but yeah like
I just I was literally just talking to
the guy beside me and that that popped
up and he was like oh go go
so then I just quickly sped up and and
it corrected I saw somebody else who
tried to uh
dude that spell is so awesome
I'm gonna let you guys hear that I'm
gonna let you guys hear the sound a
little bit for this right here
let me back it up
because again I was kind of testing I
wanted to see how far they could detect
me
I did cut right there because I stood
here forever I was talking to the
Avalanche guy like
how close can I get if I do this right
here are they going to see me and so he
was kind of explaining it
but then even then like they still don't
know where I'm at
Minister for magic himself what is going
on here only one way to find out
and again I can't get over how a lot of
other people had this bridge destroyed
then Ben was able to repero the bridge
and it didn't it didn't prompt him for
that it didn't like didn't say like
here's what you do he just tried it and
it worked so right now we've got
Expelliarmus
and then crucio and then the top one is
repero and then we have revelia or not
revelio um
disillusionment disillusionment charm
that's what we have right there
Rebellion
Jay I don't think so
I don't think we can
I didn't encounter it anywhere and I I
specifically looked
uh logs yeah PS5 PS5
oh that's a good question Apollo any
extra information you can share that
wasn't in your video we've already
talked about it some if you guys go back
and watch the replay
I'm trying to think of anything related
specifically to Hogwarts that we could
share
talked about how Boston watches our
Let's Plays that was pretty exciting I
love that
um we talked about how Alan we talked a
little bit about their inspiration from
the old games and how they how they
didn't really play a lot of the old
games so
to be excuse me to base anything from
this game off of
I don't know I'll see if I can think of
anything else
and then we had uh I cast knife oh my
goodness that came in earlier with CAD
Bane I'm so sorry I cast knife I hope
you're still here you sent in a Super
Chat thank you very much for your
support when you were flying through the
quidditch field did you get a sense of a
Vibe this might be a thing in the future
like a DLC
I wish I could say yes but I I didn't I
didn't
I don't even think there were Hoops
actually
when I flew through there
and I know that's like one of the big
things people want to is like quidditch
DLC please
but I mean that again I'm not basing
that on anything we saw or did it's just
I I shouldn't say I should say I didn't
hear anything about that one way or
another just my take from flying through
there it didn't feel like oh this is
they can make this
a game right here
but who knows man like I said they they
absolutely 100 listen to the community
they really do
quiddish you have its own full game I'm
kind of in the same boat Jenny kind of
in the same boat
can you go to prison ask a man I don't
know
don't know we didn't see anything about
that
have a good one Christy thank you for
being here hanging out
no we did not get to try that little
little pavado
the uh
no we didn't for the PS that gyro
controls for the PS5 controller nope
any major loading screens in Hogwarts
castles that all seamless great question
no major loading screens
my wife pops in
she's like trying to take I still have
like a piece of a cookie here
now she's dying laughing trying to not
be heard on stream
oh my you could say hi they think you
don't even exist
oh there we we got a hand we got a hand
let's go Mrs racket tour
dude I still had like a bite of a cookie
left right here she's trying to take
take away this
try to take away the cookie
come on now
all right now we're done
oh man that was funny
thank you
too funny
you're a wizard Harry
love the whole side quest feels very
different
from a Wizarding World story in a good
way it did Joe
when we open that tent
that was probably my biggest
jaw-dropping moment
I mean I didn't I don't know what we
were gonna find in there you know
had no idea
no idea
Chris with the Super Chat oh wave I know
we got a wave you guys who knows maybe
one day she'll join me for a live stream
maybe one day we can get her to join
and then Elwyn with another Super Chat
as well for 500 likes we get away she
already
she gave the wave I owe you a dollar 49
oh
oh that's too funny
trying to keep it relatively low so it
doesn't uh
let's see
if we get a thousand light are we close
to a thousand likes what
if we get a thousand light oh my gosh I
just oh we're four over 500.
if we get a thousand likes I mean oh my
goodness
yeah we could do
Luna is in here tonight and she's not
asleep yet so yeah we'll we'll bring
Luna on maybe if we get
maybe if we get 700 see if we can get
700. oh
and you did have to donate again to say
that
one with another Super Chat no I mean we
have 500 likes and got away
oh my gosh okay
I want to know what you guys think about
this because every I don't know if I've
ever it's hard to get people to agree on
the internet with just about anything
but
almost every Creator I heard that talked
about this not that we did not that we
disliked this mini game it was just a
little unclear and I'm not gonna say it
was broken but it just felt very I have
longer footage of this too because I I
added to this to speed it up a little
bit
um so it's it's a low Amora and then
this is what happens you get this little
lock picking game which you know we've
seen a lot of games with with lock
picking so the idea is like you have
these these green and red Sparks
and so the best way to do it is like you
just want to just do one at a time at
first I was just spinning them all like
crazy you really just want to do one at
a time so I I pushed the left one and
then I start just rotating around but
finding like the sweet spot so basically
I'm moving this around and I want this
gear over here to start spinning
and so you see it kind of twitched there
for just a second so I'm like what why
does it keep and so I'm like okay maybe
it's in this area
and then then I get it but then I also
you have to keep holding the left one
and then do the red one at the same time
you have to do that one too
and so then I started seeing that other
one Spin and so I'm like okay I think
I'm I'm kind of close wait but then my
left one started then the green one
stopped and then right there I was like
oh they're both they're both spinning
they're both working I'm just gonna keep
holding it
and then it went it worked
then it worked
so I think if they
maybe if they just like clarify a little
bit on the instructions exactly or
if they again this is where I'm like my
ignorance of Game Dev is coming into
play here if they like increase the the
window
of like Precision of like where you have
to have it held
I feel like that might make it make it
better they did tell me they said that
it's randomized so you won't get the
same exact positioning every time and I
don't think it will increase or decrease
in difficulty either I think it's just
like a set like that's how it is and
every time it's just a randomized
position
dragon
Dan how's it going
Dan we couldn't show any menus could not
show any menus
therefore I didn't even I didn't really
pull it up at all
I think the spell should just unlock it
yeah like I don't I don't hate the idea
of doing some sort of minigame with it
but it could it could use a few tweaks
that'd be interesting Chris if they gave
you the option to just like disable just
have it the spell Auto
this was
it's hard to say favorite part because I
just I loved the whole thing I loved
everything we did but this was fun
because things just went crazy right
here and this is the fight where I
really started to get better at the
combat as I mentioned in my preview I've
been playing so much God of War so just
about any time you see me jump like
right here I get the nice Parry right
there that's protego with triangle I
mean that jump is meant to be a roll so
in God of War you know it's like X to do
your role I gotta get you suppressed
Circle so it's Circle for the roll I
would have rolled forward
and I just go right in man I was like
okay they gave me crucio I'm just gonna
use it
the thing that I think will take people
the most getting used to is
when you get multiple ones unlocked
and you have to like switch with a d-pad
however and they stress this to us is
that look we're jumping you
the way you guys will experience this
organically and we'll all experience it
organically when the game comes out is
it will be a progression so I don't know
if we're going to start with four spells
or one spell or whatever but I can I can
guarantee We're not gonna start with
like eight you're not gonna start with
those multiple slots
so it will be a gradual build up to this
point right so somebody was asking about
potions earlier there was wig and weld
right there like you see how quick it
was
so I do the little that's an ancient
magic attack right there boom boom boom
the little slam on him and then right
here I miss I should have done uh
protego there but I'm really low so down
on the d-pad we get the Wigan weld
I was a little late let's see does that
one damage me it does
okay so I get back to full health
so that protego was late
and the button that you have to press
when they when they do this little spell
right
right here I think that's levioso no no
what is that one
because it's purple or I did I heard her
shout levioso though
you see I'm kind of hovering there
The Prompt that you have to press to get
out of it it changes
so I thought the first time I was like
okay it's going to be this every time
but it switches up it's a different
button each time
oh
I'm finding new stuff too I'm gonna have
to break down my own footage you guys
what the heck is this he says you after
the golden snitch
what
why would he be asking that
you after the golden snitch
poppy though Poppy's holding her own
over there
so then we get some combat going accio
and then you see the little leaves that
kind of fly around that is when uh poppy
has some sort of plant on the
battlefield that's helping us out
I didn't use that enough the R1
oh
did you guys catch this I haven't seen
anybody comment on this
I have not seen anybody comment on this
did you guys catch that
if you can't read it
you could probably you could probably
see it if you pull it up on the main
video
oh my gosh Dr sherbet and moon Lily I'm
so I think you guys are being sarcastic
that has been one of the biggest
comments on my video today
LOL it's Leviosa
I'm like I get the joke everybody's
trying to make but it actually is a
different spell in this game it's levios
oh levioso levioso o at the end
it's a different spell
we've talked about this before on stream
it is not Wingardium Leviosa it's not
so Wingardium Leviosa guys you can like
you lift the object and you move it
around
levioso
you can see the text you could see the
text in the game
it is a spell that it's basically love a
corpus without like holding them by the
ankle which Snape would invent this some
of my favorite dialogue right here
this loyalist Warrior I'm gonna rewind
it so you guys can hear him I refuse to
be defeated by a vegetable
my gosh
[Music]
I think that's my favorite line of
dialogue for the whole thing I refuse to
be eat to beat not eaten I was gonna say
I refuse to be defeated by a vegetable
ah
vegetables on the battlefield
oh
salt right
oh he was not happy
I know eaten by a vegetable
all right so here's where I finally
start getting pretty decent
I'm like okay I'm feeling it now Dodge
red one you always have to dodge the red
one
so we dodged the red
accio confringo right in your face
okay focusing on you now oh trying to
hit me from behind that's all right I
got protego you know what ancient magic
throw on this guy boom right there now I
got a little bit too close and so watch
this is I actually like this I like a
wizard if you see it's like hitting
there because the way the targeting is
it's like targeting I guess
um if there was a way to like do a
little Precision targeting on it I just
need to back up
I even tried another R1 but it hits
right in front of him
so I'm like okay I gotta just let him be
for a second let me try to reposition
there we go get a different position
then we uh accio him
and then that you see the little leaves
the first couple times I watched the
footage I could not figure out what
happened here I was like
poppy is is being held up right now
how did this dude just fall over
and then I found Poppy's little plant
that has been deployed on the
battlefield
poppy has been deployed on the
battlefield or Poppy's plan watch this
boom it just launches oh wait what did
what did they say about herbology
that makes it even better
she's literally making fun of the plant
is this what they teach in apology these
days
hold on let me make it so you guys can
hear it
and I want to turn it up to Max because
that was pretty loud
listen
she doesn't even get to finish
do we already get the animagus
oh we did I was totally talking over
that part wasn't I
I was totally talking over that part
all right we'll rewind a bit uh also
Let's see we had
let's see uh Trent six minutes ago Trent
oh my goodness I'm sorry Trent I missed
that one uh with the Super Chat thank
you Trent very much appreciate it scale
of one to ten how would you rate your
gameplay
let's see let's see so just like game
like just what I experienced not basing
it off what I guess or hope
I would say a nine I'd say a solid nine
yeah
I would say a nine
and the potential for the 10 just
because there's
there's a lot of I know that's there
that we didn't get to see and do didn't
get to see and do
yeah I would say nine like the concerns
that I have
are a
potentially could be fixed B even if
they were in the final game wouldn't
bother me too much would not bother me
too much
now I'm to the point where I'm like I
just want I want good mission for I want
Mission variety I want
um a nice feeling of progression
throughout the game as you learn these
new spells because again this section
here they were putting us further into
the game we don't know how far I think
we were like level 19 or something and
we had a lot more Spells at this point
we had access to eight rather than just
four
so yeah that's that's sort of where I'm
at now Apollo with another Super Chat as
well did you try to open the map of
argelshire oh dude people keep asking
about them
I'm so annoyed that I I didn't I didn't
do anything with the map how are you
don't come to Gryffindor so the morning
the morning of our session I couldn't
sleep the whole night I couldn't sleep
the whole night
I had flown in across three time zones
I'm eastern time so I was already like
thrown off by the time and just like the
excitement of getting to meet a lot of
these creators that I've been following
for the past year or so here
it was just like already excited from
all that and then getting to play the
game so I got up early he couldn't sleep
so I was like I'm just I'm just getting
up I'm just gonna go on get ready and so
I went down to the lobby and I was just
like taking notes like all the things I
wanted to just like handwriting it out
all the things I wanted to make sure I
tried to do and see and ask about
so I planned Apollo I planned and I I
didn't the map thing totally slipped my
mind just totally slipped my mind
if it's if anyone did it though and it's
out there a wizard Harry they probably
can't show it then again I've already
seen some uh videos that include things
they asked us not to show
just certain menus and stuff that we
were we basically weren't supposed to
show any menus other than like the uh
you were allowed to show the menu when
you hop on the Broom which I think I
even took it out of my video just to be
safe but
that was just because some of the menus
had like Dev Dev stuff in there
but yeah I didn't think I didn't think
to open it I wish I had I wish I had
Apollo
you saw one Creator try but it was cut
off oh interesting
interesting
now I know for sure I'm going to spend
easily five hours gawking at everything
before touching
any Mission once at Hogwarts right
I kept getting you know what I loved
and it wasn't I don't know that really
anticipated this but just like the
little Field Guide pages that are flying
around
those were so fun they were so fun
because it's like there was a little bit
of a challenge one time I went into the
library so the footage that you I have
way more footage of the library way more
footage of that and the greenhouse so
stay tuned to the channel this week I
also have a vlog so I
I focus so much on getting this video
out I don't even know what what's next
but I have a lot of footage of the
library a lot of footage of the
greenhouse a lot of footage of me flying
around exploring Hogwarts
and
what's the other one
oh I can't remember oh the one I showed
you guys tonight of of inside Hogwarts
the uh The little moth Quest actually I
do have that one ready I could probably
post that tomorrow
you after the golden snitch why are why
are they asking you after the golden
snitch no sorting ceremony Dan we did
not see that we did not see that
can enemies cast Avada cadaver on the
player Panda asked we didn't see
anything about that I think so
I would assume so
but we didn't see anything about that in
the gameplay
Jeremiah with a super chat yo thank you
Jeremiah and Brad choosing to become a
channel member yo thank you Brad welcome
to house wrecking tour enjoy the emotes
and enjoy the uh special Discord role
let's see make sure I didn't miss any
other channel members coming in there
guys thank you for the likes by the well
man crazy number of likes crazy number
of people here hanging out to almost
like something big happened today almost
like something big happened
but we do this thing every week guys and
we're gonna be streaming even more once
the game comes out so in the past we've
our normal stream is on Tuesday we just
did one last night
that you know what that would be fun if
tonight is your first time watching it
would be fun if you went back and
watched last night's stream when we
couldn't talk about any of this stuff
it'll be funny to go back and watch that
now
yeah we normally stream on Tuesdays
we'll definitely be doing another stream
next Tuesday
and then next week
the next
the next week
we'll be doing a big uh massive like
Monday Monday countdown stream to when
it releases presumably at midnight
hopefully we'll get some info on that
soon exactly like when it's unlocking in
each region
um yeah right now I'm assuming it's
gonna be midnight Eastern Time Jeremiah
with a super chat thank you Jeremiah
change that nine ranking to nine and
three quarters nine and three coaches
you're a wizard what is it he says to
him
he's like 93 quarters
playing a joke something like that I
can't remember thank you Jeremiah Raven
with the Super Chat as well Raven thank
you I don't see a comment with yours
Raven but thank you for the support
appreciate it
yeah Bean towns I'm uh I'm gonna be
playing it when it comes out on the
seventh the the deluxe the early one
600 yo let's go thank you guys yeah it
helps more people find the video and
then all of you who end up watching this
later in the replay Squad thank you guys
for watching as well make sure you leave
a comment
let me know uh what was your favorite
part of all the gameplay we've seen here
somebody asked about wife wants a wizard
I
don't think so and I
I think that is
on behalf of white one's a wizard wife
wants a wizard is uh I don't know that
that he's ever showed his face or
anything on stream I think he prefers to
be anonymous which is you know that's
fine
so I feel I don't know this for a fact
but I feel I feel pretty confident they
would have tried to reach out to wife
once a wizard I do
maybe dude imagine if he actually was
there and just nobody knew
that would be hilarious he was actually
there but nobody knew it was him
orders from Victor I do know for a fact
that a lot of people at Avalanche love
wife once Wizards videos though yeah
Ultra Blue what's up you did great at
least you didn't jump off a cliff I may
have should have jumped off just to show
it off
Jay good question Jake can you cast
attack spells anywhere you can cast them
anywhere why I cast a couple of them in
the library let me go back to my other
video now
let me go back to this video here
uh let's see it's toward the end
oh yeah and somebody oh my gosh I
remember somebody asking the question a
while back about loading screens there
is no loading screens we did run into a
door a few times where we would get a
spinning white symbol from the door
usually it was just like a second there
was one time where I walked up to the
door and it took an extra I had to back
up and then go back through and then it
then it went away one it's this lock
picking where is the uh what did you ask
about oh my gosh oh yeah the Spells make
it so it doesn't happen here it is it's
when I'm in the library
I was I this is one thing I wish I'd had
more time to do
to just go around and see like what can
interact and what can't
that little picture frame not that one
hold on you'll see me turn around here
in a second
because I was just kind of like oh that
stack of books looks like it could be
knocked over also giving see like look
how close I am to chairs guys no prompt
no prompt to sit down in any of these
chairs so I don't think you can like
right I was right by it right by it
okay now right here is where I just
start so this one R2 this is just like
the basic shot so I'm just kind of
trying to cast around see if it'll knock
over anything
to kind of pull that leech to me instead
I had to walk over and press the square
prompt to pick it up and then some
things in the library would interact
when I cast a spell right here picture
frame right here so see that one did
respond here and then others were not
just for the heck of it I had to cast
incendios and I do incendio I also so it
does kind of leave this like charred
look to the books couldn't get over just
how immersive and cinematic this whole
experience fell I told some of the folks
there I said This truly felt
I I mean that that last part I did I
went up some other people after
some of the WB people there I'm just
like I I felt like I was back in like I
was sitting down to watch a new movie
in The Wizarding World
Dan have a question about those pages
like fragments a page that you need to
collect World fans have dreamed two of
three pages collected I think that the
two or three pages I think those are
just like little Milestones maybe
they're part of an overall collection or
something like that
but I think it I think like the page you
get I think it is a full page
I think
and then let's see we had uh Sean with
the Super Chat what was your favorite
thing about your playthrough
oh that's so hard
it's it's a good it's a good question a
question I should have expected and
having to answer
I'm gonna say combat pretty surprised
what I'm most looking forward to is
exploring the castle but for this
particular demo I'm going to say combat
because we really didn't get to do a ton
of exploring
didn't get to do a ton of exploring
for this it was the combat because I was
just so impressed with how how it came
across I mean it was it was just it was
genuinely fun
genuinely fun and I was I didn't want it
to feel just like button mashing I
didn't want it to feel like you were
just spamming so that's why I was a
little bit worried going in like these
oh they've got this basic shots you know
like what about all the talk about some
of that all your regular spells
and yeah so the combat really really
blew me away with how good it is and how
it's going to be very difficult to
master a wizard so that's why I'm so
curious to see the actual progression
like because I think if we progress
through the game normally again they
jumped us to a further point in the game
but progressing normally like let's say
you just start off with one spell
it's going to be a lot more of a gradual
so you're going to get used to I will
say you're going to really need to
decide on what your kind of go-to spells
are and how you want to have them mapped
like on your controller
like what you want on X what you want on
Circle what you want on Square
that sort of thing
blue Powder fast travel
I did get a couple of the Fast Travel
prompts and I kind of stood right beside
it to try and see but it didn't let me
actually fast travel by it they probably
had it turned off for this I don't know
no room of requirement Cole we didn't
get to see anything with room of
requirement
um
and then we had uh let's see Elwyn with
another Super Chat 600 likes convenient
oh my gosh you guys are crazy
you guys are awesome
I'm pretty sure that's a record for
Deering alive pretty sure that's a
record
and then we had dream and plays games
with another Super Chat thank you so
much dreaming pre-ordered Deluxe today
on Playstation it said I could play on
the seventh at midnight gotcha good deal
good deal
yeah I think I think that's how it's
going to be like for us it'll be
midnight like Eastern Time
musical cue that plays right here see
that's where a lot of people thought
you'd be able to sit
we saw this little prompt in a previous
footage that they showed
detail but yeah it's a it's it's use
when you walk up to that use is the
prompt that you get
and then we had let's see dreaming and
we had pineapple cheers again with
another Super Chat Hogwarts looks big of
flying around how do you feel about the
sense of scale okay
thank you for the chat I love this
question and this is part of the reason
I've Loved getting to watch all the
different footage today from all the
different creators I truly mean when I
when I found something new in every ones
that I watched like James expect to go
in his footage he went a different way
around the top of Hogwarts I went the
other way so when you when you see his
footage you see like the other side of
Hogwarts
he went like to the left and I went to
the right like I went toward The
Boathouse and all that welcome and then
he went the other way like the little
like Main Court the iconic Courtyard in
that area I don't even think I went
around there so yeah the sense of scale
was great like flying up to that stained
glass window
which I show in this video that might be
one of my favorite just single pieces of
imagery that they've released about this
game is that you guys if you guys were
here last night man that was I was
dropping hints you obviously you didn't
know it was a hint but we talked about
that that picture with the stained glass
windows because we were watching the
winter ASMR and there's a shot of it in
there and I was telling you guys I was
like I love this I love these windows so
much such a good spot
here's what I can't wait to do
I can't wait to see them at night
I can't wait to see them at night flying
outside Hogwarts at night oh I can't
wait
cannot wait and then we had CAD Bane
Bounty Hunter wait is that another one I
think that's another one are you gonna
at least finish order the feeds before
hog looks like this comes out really
like the throwback of it if not no big
deal a cad Bane Bounty Hunter thank you
for your support on the live on the uh
the let's plays
let me let me think about before I
answer this I want to I want to I will
say that I don't know if I'm gonna have
the time I don't know
who knows I just don't know I am um
these next two weeks guys they're gonna
be insane they're gonna be insane I'm
hoping like this weekend I'm really
gonna try to just take it easy
catch up a little bit
and just uh
just try to get some rest dude
I uh like I said I got there on a
Wednesday evening
hung out with some creators that night
didn't we didn't stay up too late
because we knew we had to to be up the
next day for the gameplay did the game
play and then after the gameplay we we
had lunch up there we talked to Boston
and Allen talk to some of the WB folks
met some of the other creators there
then Miranda and I went over to
Universal we spent like the whole
afternoon at Universal already like
checking out the Wizarding World
couldn't get into the Mario park though
I was so mad it's not officially open
yet so I couldn't get into the Mario
park we spent the afternoon there had
dinner three Broomsticks then we all
like James Miranda and and I we all had
late flights that night we were all like
East Coast time
so we were all having to take red eye
flights back
and so we get to the airport and it was
already pretty late and then we just we
just sat there and talked we just talked
the whole time I filmed one of my Vlogs
that I filmed is in the airport with
Miranda and James after after
everything's done we're just there in
the airport like
that any good about to fall over so I
couldn't sleep on the airplane could not
sleep on the airplane so we I got on
so Pacific time it was like 11 something
11 40 or so I landed
at like 6 40 my time wizard 6 40 A.M
and then I had to drive about an hour to
get to my house where I live so I just I
got some breakfast got some caffeine
drove home and then just immediately
went to sleep slept four or five hours
or so but I'm still catching up I'm
still catching up because then when we
got back like that's when the hard work
began right that's when we had to get
all these videos ready and
here in the bottom right dude I tell you
when you have an opportunity like this
man I knew
this had to be good this had to be a
good video like it had had to be one of
my best videos here's a fun little
behind the scenes for you guys I
wrote the video I scripted this one out
recorded it and I I rarely ever
do this rarely ever the wizard I
scrapped
I scrapped the whole intro rewrote the
intro
and recorded it all again I hardly ever
re-recording I just hardly ever do it
hardly ever do it usually it's now I'll
do multiple takes like I'll be like
people at the internet retro record tour
here's what we're showing today I don't
like how that sounds here's what we were
doing today I'll do that a lot but doing
the whole thing again never but I
listened to it and I was like
no no it's not it's not hitting it's
missing something so I read it the whole
thing
um and so just getting all this stuff
ready it's been a lot it's been a lot
but it's been exciting so I need to
catch up on sleep however CAD Bane's
like oh my gosh I didn't expect I just
wanted to get I wanted a simple yes or
no dude you didn't have to go relax
relax
no Kevin it was a good question I want
to I want to but I don't know if I'm
gonna have any time we'll see though
we'll see I definitely do re even after
Hogwarts comes out I mean I want to
replay through them all at some point
although after playing Hogwarts Legacy
let me tell you guys it's gonna be hard
to go back to those old games
It's gotta be hard to go back man
all right let's see we had a couple of
other things jumping in there looks like
oh man like five six new Seven Subs then
we had elwin gifting another five
memberships five more members of house
rack and tour
exclamation point Discord guys you get a
special role there whenever you're a
channel member you also get access to
special Emoji here in the chat which
I almost guarantee we've unlocked some
more emotes now that I need to and
cadbane who just asked one of the
questions in the Super Chat cadbane was
gifted one of those memberships
invisible Guardian Coco nutmeg the poet
congrats on those gifted memberships
guys make sure if you got anybody
tonight if you got a gifted membership
make sure you thank the person who
gifted you and then a bunch of other
subscribers just just came in as well
thank you guys thank you guys so much
for all the love and support jet lag is
real right Draven hydrate Harry Potter
from the Goblet of Fire only this time I
haven't even I haven't even opened it
man
I haven't even opened it
I did have a I had like a some milk with
my cookie though earlier
that's right oh my goodness all right
what do you guys uh your video is doing
so well thank you David yeah it's
both it's uh it is it's doing very well
it's doing very well let's see what are
we at 241 000 views in a day
right here maybe I stepped a little bit
yeah dude and he overheard me that's
that's unreal
that's unreal I uh like the invisibility
I'll never forget when I knew
when I first had a video kind of go not
even I'm not even gonna use the word
viral but when it started to like gain
some traction
it was a video about
it was about
um when Nintendo was making the Mario
oh whatever that Mario 30th Anniversary
pack or something was
and it uh
it was it got like a thousand views or
something when right when I posted it
and I was just like for us
oh my gosh you know oh my gosh
what is this and I remember watching the
counter
it's like Oh I'm a tooth it's a 2000 now
what
all right and now let's have a video I
mean
yeah it's it's crazy it's crazy
but it's all thanks to you guys man it's
all thanks to you guys
800 plus people watching
oh my gosh
you ever like it's one thing to like see
a number but then you actually think
like if we had a room full of 800 people
like imagine if we were all just in a
room together right now
such a different vibe you're all like
probably cozied up you know some of you
are on the couch some of you may be in
bed some of you may be like having your
lunch having your dinner watching on
your iPad watch it on your phone
some of you may Elwyn oh my gosh
I hope Ellen doesn't mind me sharing
this I don't think Owen will I don't
think so
so Ellen when I said I was it was before
a stream a few weeks ago
Elwyn sends me a picture was like all
ready for the stream and it's just a
shot of I guess I think this was elwyn's
like bedroom wall and she has a
projector
a massive projector magic attack massive
projector and I just I'm like okay my
that my face I don't need to see my face
that big that is way too big my face is
way too big on a freaking projector
but it goes to show elwyn's dedication
it does somebody said watching it work a
nice
channel members oh let's that's actually
a good question I don't know if you type
if YouTube has a real-time counter on
that but let me I can check
it has it's had the opposite effect let
us take a look at how many channel
members
how many are officially part of that
Dragon tour
my two hours
we go here we go here
oh I don't think that's updated I don't
think it's updated from tonight
it says 2 30. I think that was from last
night I don't think it's added tonight's
end
least for me I don't think
2 30. even 2 30. insane
insane
oh wait what what Bob watching on a
projector too are you serious
how you guys like the projectors do you
do you game on them too or do you just
use them for movies
I mean they've got to be great space
saving for space saving right
occasionally as long as you have a good
solid wall
one where you have to kind of back up
and wait all in I remember back in the
day though like when people first like
the quality just wasn't that great like
but now they're probably so so much more
advanced
the animagus animation looks so clean I
wish I'd focused a little bit more right
when the transformation happened
I wish I had focused more on that
invisible Guardian in bed
Spud can't wait to play without the hood
I know I can't wait to see what all we
can tweak from the hood like the whole
thing that I showed off with the um the
little Golden Trail
this little screen I showed that off
because I think there's a lot of new
players
who are maybe playing video game for the
first time or maybe the first time in a
long time who are just Harry Potter fans
it's fine
the game itself I don't know if I'll use
that Golden Trail or not I don't know
I probably will I feel like when you're
out in the open world it'd be really
useful but navigating Hogwarts maybe
there'll be a way to turn that off too
like if you eventually just want to have
that off L1 is a pro Elwyn is L one is
totally a pro the moon Lily right right
so it's like I had to hold did you not
see that Nico did you not see that I see
Nico with the S with the SMH as well
uh-oh uh oh Nico
exactly where you have them just movies
for the projector gotcha
yeah I feel like for a movie experience
they'd be really really solid increase
and we can't really see the window but
just make it so it doesn't have to be so
precise and true yeah Nico's like I'm
seeing who my true friends are I'm
seeing my actual footage to see how long
did it take me here to actually get
through this it's still only which is
not
how was the experience mahatu it was
awesome exactly it was awesome so
I don't wanna
I mean like like game aside
game aside even if the game had been bad
which it wasn't but even if the game had
been bad just for meeting the creators
and making
I'll just say it lifelong friendships
I can't wait to do it to do it again
going even if it's not with WB like
whatever you know if just the group of
us organizing a trip to Wizarding World
or something you know
I can't wait to do it again I mean James
said it today on his channel and I've
said it before too like some people I
said it last night like there's some
people in your life you just you just
Vibe with you know and when you find
those people you gotta stick close to
them
stick close to them I I didn't talk
about the fact that I met James for the
first time uh ghost man yes I'm
definitely gonna stream and post
Hogwarts Legacy stuff when the game
comes out
in a way that works best for you I need
to talk about James for a second you
guys
around the castle and so that was the
first time James and I had ever met
and first for literally first thing I
did was I gave him a big hug had to give
him a big hug right away that's where I
say I wish I'd had like a camera camera
crew with me I told my wife I was like
next time you got it you gotta come with
me for something like this so then you
can I want you to just just film like
everything please which she's good at
that like anytime we're out with a
family
any of the books she's always like
picture picture let's take pictures
let's take pictures we need to take
pictures take pictures take pictures
experience and I just don't think that I
just don't think that way so I wish I'd
had footage of James and I meeting for
the first time I mean just like
how he is on stream man I told him one
of the first things that like when you
watch his stream it's just like his
jovial nature right you just love
hanging out with the guy
and I told him right away I was like
you're a wizard some people can fake
that kind of stuff and it's like you can
you could tell you could tell like oh
they're putting on the hello guys I'm
happy today I'm I'm being happy for
everybody James like just the enthusiasm
you can't fake
you can't fake that so I already knew
like I knew I've talked to him enough
off stream offline I knew I was like I
know exactly how he's going to be in
person so the first thing I do is like
have I have to go give him a big hug and
he just has this huge smile on his face
I hope I had I'm sure I was smiling too
huge smile on his face and then wizard
PhD was like so James was sitting like
right here
so I give James a hug then uh wizard
tricks was here Brita was there
wizard PhD and then um Benjamin snells
on the other side
so I was like I gotta give you a hug
James gotta give you a hug
and it's just like it's like I've known
in my whole life it's like I've known in
my whole life like just
one of the game's main missions as I've
gotten older as I've gotten older in
life you guys like
I hate small talk
I hate
it should be really all for a minute
I hate it
I hate it it's so it's so weird and
awkward
and yes sometimes you have to do it
actually get into the gameplay I'm
actually pretty surprised and so it was
kind of like apprehensive a little bit
apprehensive to be honest about an event
like this
and I don't think I had any
small talk with anybody wanted to jump
right in any small talk it was all like
real conversation and I guess that's
like the beauty of the internet like the
fact that we already like yeah we we
haven't met physically but we already
kind of know each other from interacting
in in Discord groups and on streams and
in Twitter DMS and even you know I've
had James on the live stream and
um I've talked with Ben before on
Twitter
um we did a big live stream with Alex
podcast now and Andy reloads and all
those guys and and wizard PhD and even
like nightly nerd and last Marauder and
Hogwarts I can see explain like
we talked with all these people before
so you never know like when you actually
meet them in person like
how's it going to be right how's it
are we gonna have that like yeah hey
how's it going you can swim no
nope not at all
not at all and I really wish
particularly with um like I barely got
to spend any time with with Lynette and
Brita and
wizard tricks uh Kellen is is his name
and then even even Ben snow I didn't get
really a chance to spend as much time
with them we talked and hung out a
little bit that night but then James and
I we had the whole morning and the whole
gameplay session and then we had the
whole time at the airport while we were
waiting for our red eye flights to just
to just talk
and I talked about how the two-hour
gameplay session flew by the whole the
whole two days flew by and Miranda
Lauren as well like didn't even hadn't
he never even met her had never even met
Miranda and as soon as she was in the uh
she was in the um the gameplay session
with us
and so I was like I was like what's your
channel and she told me the name and I
was like I've heard of this
and I instantly remember I was like I've
seen your thumbnail right when she said
it it clicked I was like you've been on
my recommended page before I have seen
your thumbnail so I pulled her up and
shirt off I was like oh yeah you've
played you've played God of War you did
a video where you reacted to one of the
Hogwarts Legacy trailers
and so even with her like we hadn't
interacted at all but just we like hit
it off man we just we all just we just
Vibe together it was just such a just
good vibes
Good Vibes all around man
Good Vibes all around and like all I can
keep thinking about is like when it just
wasn't long enough that's that's my one
complaint wish we could have stayed like
a week
like they had absolutely nailed them
staying like a week would have been
awesome
only did they get the music right but
also all of them extra people sound us
that are going to happen here and there
Lauren D I'm begging for no one to talk
to me
oh goodness
going downhill uh whatever they what's
what's chat done Dr sherbet
jealous hobo I mean I can't lie it was
it was a it was a super fun experience
oh no is that what's getting uh oh Nico
and elwin oh my gosh
maybe we're just gonna have to have a
big gathering in real life where we all
meet and we can mend the fences
stumped by an empty painting we can mend
the
what is it we can mend
the wounds that have been formed here
tonight I'm very disappointed
oh my gosh Jay Felix
with a super chat like eight minutes ago
Jay I hope you're still here dude I'm so
sorry
I'm so sorry that I didn't see it until
now my friend's husband helped design
Super Mario World Orlando
he too has an unbreakable vow
unfortunately it looks awesome though
love today's vids AJ thank you so much
so glad you enjoyed the videos that was
like the one disappointment of my trip
we had been told that they were letting
some people in on kind of like a trial
to like test some things out
so the the one in I think the one in
Orlando doesn't open for a bit but the
one in La opens next month it opens in
February that was like my one
disappointment because I wanted to see
that I did get to go in the Mario store
though which is pretty cool
I didn't buy anything though because I
was thinking oh they don't have to carry
it all back on the plane
still here nice Jay sorry it took me so
long to get to it dude let me make sure
I didn't miss anybody else lots of new
subscribers coming in guys thank you all
for subscribing we hit 40K today by the
way
40K subscribers thank you all for the
the crazy love and support
and we're we're on our way to 41k
on our way to 41k thank you all for
subscribing and then let's see back at
the top now we've got beanie bird with a
sewer chat beanie bird what magical
Beast are you excited to see oh so like
one we haven't seen yet
oh this is a good question so we have
seen let's try to think of what we've
seen we've seen Moon calves we've seen
grab horns we've seen dragons
we saw Doug bugs
a Doug bog going crazy
what else what else
no art book spoilers by the way guys yes
I know they've they're in there but
we're not gonna talk about that here
like so my favorite one that I always
say we don't know
hey again we're not no spoilers guys the
Phoenix I'd love to see a phoenix in
game I think that'd be awesome
and then another one that would be
awesome we've seen hippogriffs too
already and we've seen the spiders
I think the Thunderbird would be cool
too I just love the visual look of that
thing but
I know that one's not um I don't think
they live according to the lore I don't
think they live in the area so we might
have to go somewhere else
use my inventory oh Kelpie would be a
good one
we leave Orlando's opening February what
I didn't think the Orlando one was like
I didn't think they'd even started on
the Orlando one yet
no way if they are I'm gonna I'm gonna
have to make a trip there
we did go we did get to go through the
Harry Potter The Wizarding World though
out there
so they don't have the um
they don't have Diagon Alley at that one
yet which I don't know if they even have
plans to add it because the spacing
there is so different from the one in
Orlando
which I haven't even been to Orlando
since they've added Diagon Alley
honestly after being there
after being in La it makes me want to go
back to Orlando again to do the Diagon
Alley stuff so I I rode the main ride is
the uh it's called Harry Potter and the
Forbidden Journey
and I'd forgot I remember parts of the
rut oh my gosh I've got to bring this
home it's at my my office at work we
have the picture you know how a lot of
the rides at amusement parks they take
pictures of you
we bought this picture because it was so
good
actually if I show that picture we'll
probably never get my wife on stream
because she'll be very mad at me she's
like she's very she doesn't like crazy
thrill rides okay
I mean anything like she doesn't want to
do any upside down which this doesn't go
upside down it comes pretty close but
she's like I don't want to be scared
going fast you know like a nice little
fast roller coaster no upside down she's
good with that
we get her on this Forbidden Journey
ride which is not a roller coaster it's
more like kind of like a Thrill Ride if
you've never been there or ridden it
it's sort of like what do you call a
Thrill Ride it uses a combination of
like physical actual animatronics and
also
like a really giant screens like you
don't feel like it's a screen because it
completely kind of wraps around you
hey dude the picture that we got from
that it was in the row it was me my wife
my cousin who's a huge Potter fan and
then my sister on the other side
the picture
it's like I have this huge grin on my
face exactly my cousin has this huge
grin on his face my sister huge grin on
her face and then my wife is just like
enough ancient this look of pure Terror
pure Terror and the part when they take
this the picture it's like where the the
acromantula or they're like dropping in
it was an insta buy it was an insta buy
I just had to buy it right away
we had to buy it right away so I still
have it but it's in my office at work I
need to bring it home so I can show it
to you guys sometime
oh Elle wouldn't that be awesome maybe
one day maybe one day look at that it's
like the Weasley family tent right in
Harry Potter but yeah the ride is it's
really fun it's basically just like a uh
every scary creature in Hogwarts they're
gonna throw at you like back to back to
back
Jenny Jenny talk about motion sickness
Jenny I think
I think I might start to be the same way
I think it might be a sign of my old age
and I'm very sad by it so Miranda and I
I was like Miranda and I went to the
park together I was like what are you
remember what do you like to ride how
how crazy do you uh want to go she's
like oh I I'll write anything okay good
I'll write anything too so we want to do
that one twice
first time
great skills didn't feel anything then
we came back later and we wrote it again
and something about that second time
I think it was when I stepped off the
ride because this ride the way you get
on this ride it's really interesting
they have like these uh almost like
those little ramps that go back and
forth at airports and such
but this ramp continuously moves and
same thing for when you get on like you
gotta you gotta get on and it keep it
will keep moving it's pretty long so
it's like you got there's there's a
margin for error if somebody like Falls
or something and of course they could
stop it at any time if they wanted to
but then it's the same thing when you
when you're getting off
exactly nymph exactly the moving
platform
so then after we wrote it the second
time we're getting off and I just like I
stepped and I wasn't prepared for the
movement yet and I didn't completely
fall I regained you know I regain my
balance quickly but then when we got out
I was kind of like
that made me a little bit dizzy that
time
what was that
is this an age thing
oh I hope not
but I know what you're talking about
Jenny I know I know what you're talking
about now
Nico 25 and get motion sickness at the
most basic of rides oh man it's funny I
went on a really like when I was young I
was terrified and then I hit this period
where
fun it was actually at Universal in
Orlando Islands of Adventure Incredible
Hulk coaster
my uncle and my my younger cousins were
riding that roller coaster
and that that one goes fast upside down
lots of turns
and I was just like they were telling me
like you could do it you could do it you
could do it you'll love it you'll love
it it's like all right I'm doing it
nymph I loved it dude and that was it I
was I was like I'll write anything now
I'll write anything I mentioned that
anything I'll do it all right
and ever since then I've been the same
I've been this I've been exactly like
that I'll write anything don't care but
now I'm I'm hoping that I'm not starting
to hit that point where now the other
part is we hadn't eaten yet so I'm I'm
thinking I was just like drained from
the day that's what I'm gonna tell
myself I was just drained didn't have
enough
didn't have enough protein didn't have
fluids in me I was drained needed to
stop and eat that's that's what I'm
gonna tell myself was the problem
yeah the Hulk coaster dude it's it's
still my favorite roller coaster ever
you if I did the beginning is unlike
anything it's just it's just awesome
you're just so used to I mean the
traditional roller coaster right it's
like click click click click click click
click click okay we're up now we're
gonna have the fun with Hulk it it
launches you
launches you and just the sound effects
he's like this time I think it's going
to work and then you just hear warning
warning no no and then you just feel
that launch the beginning of Hulk is
like the greatest
start to a roller coaster it's so good
one of those three times you can see
that he used to be scared of roller
coasters close your eyes I know it
doesn't make sense it's easier when you
open your eyes
yeah yeah
that's right Shiloh yes I was thinking
Thunderbirds were U.S yeah that's when
we saw them in Fantastic Beasts
getting the new wand what's the new wand
Jake
I've heard a lot about Kingda Ka yes
never ridden it but I've heard a lot
about it
you're Dismount the broom you'll see
these students kind of just appear out
of nowhere they're not here when I'm
flying in velocity coaster is way better
than where's uh where's velocity coaster
at
least
Thiago would you recommend pre-ordering
Deluxe or standard edition Okay so
here's what it really comes down to it's
a 10 difference
if you want any game like this I mean
here's here's the things if you want
Early Access three days
that's kind of a fading benefit that's
going to go away
but if you really want to play it three
days early that's one thing if it was
just that I'd say no
then the other things you get you get
the dark arts battle arena which they
showed off in the second gameplay
showcase so you get to know exactly what
that is and then you get like a dark
arts cosmetic set
and
I think that's it right guys
I think that's it
so that I mean that's like you decide is
that work is that worth ten dollars or
not
that were ten dollars a night if it is
then yeah go for it now if you're on
like PS4 or Xbox you also if you do the
digital Deluxe you get a free upgrade so
you could also get like ps4 version and
a PS5 version
so maybe increase so that's what it
comes down to
one roller coaster in a Warner Brothers
theme park in Madrid that's unbelievable
stunt show
I haven't heard of that one
coaster oh it must be a new thing see
it's been so long since I've been to
Islands
Islands of Adventure is one of my
favorite Parks though absolutely
love to go there I was particularly
impressed honestly the thestral mount
wait the thestral
not have that D1 yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah the thestral amount it's the Onyx
hippogriff that's with any pre-order yep
yep good catch good catch
no Professor Baxter the haunted
hogsmeade shop is any PlayStation as far
as how it feels to move around the world
uh version any PlayStation version for
one year then it will come to everything
timed exclusive yep Dr sherbet got it
convince your boss get a console to play
Hogwarts Legacy oh nice
yeah right Lorena it's like the dark uh
the black hippogriff that you also get
yep giving players options for different
places Cloud Roth have always wanted to
go to Cedar Point never never been able
to
all right guys
we have hit just
ridiculous number of likes
oh wait what the heck I just now saw
this comment from uh
along right here was a little bit
surprising that accio didn't work to
kind of pull that oh no
oh no Stargazer Tim we got a fan
I won't read this on
right here YouTube's like uh trying to
like I had to cast
wait I saw Tim's uh I saw Stargazer
Tim's super chat or no I think star keys
are Tim gifted
I'm gonna have to check into that
so Mew store dark arts Garrison hat
with the
digital Deluxe only
not standard Deluxe
weird I know I know
all right so let's do our random bit of
Harry Potter quote trivia because you
guys were so awesome with the likes
tonight so whenever we hit a hundred
watch we might we might need to raise
this
we might need to raise we might need to
raise this uh
wands at the ready witches
yeah whenever we hit 100 we we uh do um
ran a bit of Harry Potter cool trivia
so let's do it
and then when we hit 200 we do a I feel
like we got so many people tonight guys
I feel like we're gonna have to go to I
feel like we're gonna have to go to Old
Faithful for the Harry Potter impression
tonight I feel like I'm gonna have to
dust off the OG
show off my best
I think we gotta go olivander
I think we gotta go olivander tonight
guys
so here's how we play the the quote game
though I pick a random quote from the US
versions of Harry Potter you don't know
which book grounds as well as parts of
the castle itself and then you are
tasked with naming the character who
said it
and
which book
so I thought last night's was going to
be difficult and of course of course
Brittany I haven't seen brit Brittany I
was like I haven't seen Brittany comment
all night I bet Brittany is going to
jump in
Brittany gets it every time
right in and the first thing Brittany
how about this you could still answer
just give them give everybody else like
give them like a good 15 seconds give
them a good 15 seconds
and then Brittany can tell you all what
the answer is
imagine if one day Britney's like
actually I was uh I was an editor for
the first for all the books
well but by and large all right let's
see I'm super excited I'm gonna skip it
super excited all right I've got okay
we've got the book
gorgeous window you may recall seeing
this image back when the game's release
date was confirmed they used it in a
screenshot here but now actually getting
to see oh oh oh see I feel like there's
a balance when it comes to quotes
because if you give if I don't give you
any context within the quote then it's
just almost impossible
okay fine we'll go difficult we got a
lot of people here let's go difficult
tonight it's very short I warn you I
warn you but we've we've went easier
we've went easier the past couple times
of the castle this is the ultimate test
if Britney gets this then Britney's like
officially she was an editor on the
books or something
you guys got to be mad because it's so
short are you serious professor
that's it that's your quote
are you serious professor
let's see if anybody gets that
could light literally be
anybody
all right let's see we got a Ron hapla
Prince Draco book two
Harry book five Draco book four Dr
sherbet really this is like the ultimate
test for Brittany right here
that's what this is
that's what this is the ultimate test
for Brittany Ron book six Hermione book
six Harry Potter haploid Prince Hermione
to Umbridge Draco book one one feathers
nailed it there we go one of the books
said by one of the students a few more
seconds Draco book one see this one is
so generic like I wouldn't be surprised
if that said multiple times
wouldn't be surprised if it said
multiple times
I think somebody looked it up I think
somebody looked it up
Brittany doesn't know oh we finally
stumped her absolutely
we finally stumped her somebody just
said it
somebody just said it hold on let me see
if two said oh two people said it
two people said it
you guys looked it up didn't you you
Googled it you Googled it they're like
oh is he actually gonna give something
away for this I'm looking up no it's
just for fun guys sorry it's it's
literally just just a little fun game we
do
anyone who said
I think it's in the book Jake said no
I'll read you guys the full thing here
anybody who said Oliver wood
in book one
congratulations
congratulations because you are correct
here's the full line here's the full
line
Potter this is Oliver wood would I've
found you a Seeker Woods expression
changed from puzzlement to Delight are
you serious professor
absolutely said Professor McGonagall
crisply the boy's unnatural I've never
seen anything like it was that your
first time on a broomstick putter
the original book one there you go there
you go
the poacher spoke of this area we
finally stumped Britney we finally did
it
I would but quiet yeah yeah
yes indeed hey Leah thank you for being
here have a good one
have a good one
for what in book one he was there all
along
next time yeah next time the quote is
the
foreign
who understood that reference to here
we'll see we'll see who understood that
one
oh man
McGonagall impression we should do
McGonagall sometime
all right so here's the the impression
we're going with one of the ogs tonight
this is this is my I want to set the bar
high for all the new people hanging out
in the chat tonight whenever we hit 200
likes we do it do an impression from the
Harry Potter series
uh we've done Malfoy we've done
Bellatrix we've done umbrage people were
pleasantly surprised by the umbrage
I will
that was last night it's fresh in my
memory let's see we've done Snape was
probably my worst because Alan Rickman
dude he's just
so so tough to do now and Rickman
you may have done Hagrid one time but my
best my best my best
is Ollivander
Ollivander dude
so here it is I'll make it I'll make it
a nice here we go let's let's mute the
let's mute all the the sound so you
don't have any sound
coming from that there we go there we go
already got already got the lines
already got the lines it's gonna be a
good one I'm gonna have a lengthy
lengthy line for you guys
all right here we go
I wondered when I'd be seeing you Mr
Potter
it seems only yesterday that's your
mother and father we're in here buying
their first ones
we'll give it a wave
no definitely not
and then a little bit of time
curious
very
I'm sorry sir but what's curious
I remember every wand I've ever sold Mr
Potter and it just so happens the
Phoenix whose Tailfeather resides in
your wand gave another feather
just one other
it is curious that you should be
destined for this wand
when it's brother
gave you that scar
um
then you get the music the music comes
in
oh
see you guys you guys got two in one I
did like a young Harry too
I'm sorry sir but what's curious
oh I love doing the Ollivander
I love doing all of it
thank you guys thank you
thank you
thank you as I bashed my head into the
uh
John Hurt yeah yeah I think I think it's
John Hurt right John hurts the name of
the guy who did
who played Ollivander
oh wait somebody said
Potter Puppet Pals I probably could do
that Snape
what's the Mysterious Ticking Noise
some dude that's like early days of
YouTube Right early days of YouTube
Elwood with another elwin
Owen save your money another Super Chat
700 likes no way let's go 700 and then
maestrix just with a random Super Chat
don't even see a comment with that one
thank you so much maestrix
appreciate your support and then we had
Jay Felix again with the supersets
super Set Super Chat solid 12 out of 10
impression thank you Jay thank you yeah
I had had to dust out dust out one of
the old one of my go-to's one of my
go-to's for you guys
see chat won't always let me get away
with that
they want new they want to hear new
stuff you gotta gotta keep the material
fresh
so we try to do that and you know what
is she oh Luna got up okay hold on I'll
let I'll bring Luna over too okay for
people who haven't got to see Luna
before
you're a wizard Harry
don't worry she wasn't asleep
you're a wizard actually I don't I don't
need the headphones
hold on she's she's camera shy too
I think she actually knows it's like she
actually knows she's not normally over
here
no you're not normally over here are you
not normally over here
everyone wanted to see you I know it
sounds weird but there's like I don't
know how many you've got several hundred
people I said they're up there they're
up there watching
don't you know dogs think we're like the
weirdest creatures
they think we're the weirdest creatures
all right thank you
thank you she's like okay I'm done but
I'm done all right goodbye
I found Goblin armor let's keep
searching but and yes if you guys are
new here she is named Luna for the
reasons you
for reasons you would expect
you guys like the Harry Potter 2 the
young Harry the young Harry
last night they wanted me they got me
doing the not me no Hermione
you
Phillip hey Phillip what's up dude good
to see you here Phillip let's take a
closer look
they won't be happy thanks for thanks
for stopping by Philip game looks great
special performance I know dude I was so
safe I was so glad they let us switch to
Performance I told them to I was like I
was like people want to see performance
mode
the times are changing the time like I
know people want to show off Fidelity
mode because when you get screenshots
and stuff that's when the game looks
great and all but
like like Gamers like actually playing
it through they wanna they wanna see how
smooth it can be
thank you yeah yeah guys she uh I'm
happy to break I'll bring her up anytime
but except when she's just like totally
passed out in her bed I'm not gonna
bother and tonight she wasn't in the bed
she was just laying a little bit over
here beside me honey at Bane another
Super
Luda OMG so freaking cute I have to get
her some new treats with that oh with
that uh Super Chat CAD Bean
have to get some new new treats
wonder if story mode gets rid of the
quest area limit
I don't think so I wouldn't think so
I wouldn't think so
okay guys
this has been a crazy few days a crazy
few days
um again I started off the stream
thanking all of you guys and I will end
the stream the same way because I have
no doubt we would have not
you know if if we didn't have this type
of community that we have then we
wouldn't have had an opportunity like
this so
it's all thanks to you guys and the
support you have I know people still
have a ton of questions
I still have a lot of questions but and
and I still have there's probably many
questions that I could answer that I've
they just haven't came to me yet people
haven't asked
I've got so much more footage that I'm
gonna have to get through and I've got
more videos planned but we're officially
hitting that point now where it's like
I mean less than two weeks so we've we
pick and choose now right we pick and
choose we got to decide what are the big
things that we're gonna hit on before
launch I'm sure that they're gonna have
some more stuff
um I thought I thought today was really
cool though it was really cool you know
they the Hogwarts Legacy accounts they
they were highlighting the creators man
like they were retweeting and sharing
stuff from creators and they kind of
took a back seat today and let you know
got to got to sit back and see
see what people thought you know all
these all these creators who had a
chance to play the game so I don't know
I don't know if they're gonna keep the
Daily Posts going now maybe they picked
that back up tomorrow or they might just
let things they might just like then
things settle for for a couple days or
so but you can guarantee there's going
to be more stuff leading up to launch
um
I'm trying to think of like any other
big things maybe if they uh
if they want to put I feel like we'll
get something about
release times because I feel like that's
been a big question is people are like
when's it releasing
in my territory even though I mean it's
you can pretty much check by looking on
the PlayStation store and all that the
WB game support account is answering a
ton of questions the port key game
support website has been answering a ton
of questions as well and then Jay had
another Super Chat hey thank you Jay put
this toward the toys for Luna fun thank
you Jay
thank you dude gotta head out have a
great night thank you for being here Jay
good to see you
but yeah so I mean
I'm gonna have to decide you know what
are gonna be the the final couple videos
that we make
in in the lead up to the game's release
what are the final couple videos gonna
be I am in a race I'm for sure gonna
release a couple more of the footage
that I have if you guys weren't here
early in the Stream if you rewind you
can see a I showed off the
um what was it called like the moth
Quest moth to a flame Quest
is very short it's like a little three
minute
side puzzle thing that you do I'm
probably gonna post that to the channel
at some point maybe something from her
biology maybe something from library and
just like General exploring Hogwarts but
it's not going to be like a big heavily
produced commentary kind of video
and then
so that'll probably be this week
we'll see if they release anything else
big and then next week we'll probably
have like two two or so more videos
before before the release and then we'll
be back for next week's Tuesday stream
so everybody who stopped by tonight hope
to see you there again Moon Lily with
another Super chat bye retro thank you
for such an amazing content-filled day
and again congratulations well thank you
moonly thank you for all the support and
for watching the videos
um man like I've been so excited for
this day like just so excited to be able
to talk about this trip and to be able
to
not I mean the game talk about the game
is great but being able to talk to you
guys about meeting James and meeting
people like Miranda and wizard PhD and
and Boston and Alan and all the people
that WB who again I don't know if they
want their names out there so that's why
I'm not gonna say their names but
running into Chandler and Eric in the
airport like all that stuff
I hope I'm
I I know it trust me I know
not a lot of people get opportunities
like this I get it it is not flossed on
me
um which is why I'm I'm so very thankful
to have to have this chance and again
like you guys you guys make that
possible you really do
you really do
um and then just it just in general like
it was just such a fun event just such a
fun event I wish it would have been like
three days longer wish I would have had
more time to spend with all these folks
um but it was a great man it was great
I'm on Twitter as well at retro wrecking
tour we have a Discord exclamation point
Discord in the chat right now and it'll
give you the link for it
so I'm around it's not like uh you guys
can't reach out and ask questions so if
you think of anything else and these
week and a half two weeks that we have
left
um I could try to answer things on
Twitter
try to answer things in uh in future
videos as well so yeah I'll be around
I'll be around
and Chris with another Super Chat to
close us out here Chris thank you so
much take care everyone be sure to
hydrate that's the first thing I'm gonna
do when I hop off I had this
Cherry Coke Zero as you guys know my
go-to drink I had it over here this
whole time and I just never opened it
because we just got rolling like I still
feel like there's so many stories that I
didn't even
it was such a short amount of time but
so many stories I didn't get a chance to
tell
I want to do
don't lock this in don't lock this in
I'm I have no idea there's only two
weeks we can have left I don't know if
we'll be able to pull this off but I
want to do a stream
with at least a few of us I know we
wouldn't be able to get everybody but at
least a few of us who went
just that's like more like a hangout
kind of talk about our general
experience I hope we might be able to do
something like that but we'll see we'll
see so guys thank you all so much enjoy
the videos
go back re-watch them let you know let
me know what what stuff you find we
found like it's
quite literally my footage and we found
stuff tonight that I hadn't even caught
yet when I've I've edited the video
watched it I don't know how many times
and we found stuff that I didn't see
before so let me know any things any
things you spot that you think are cool
we'll try to highlight them next week on
the uh on the Tuesday live stream but um
hope you guys have a fantastic rest of
your week certainly been an amazing day
and again thank you all so much I'll
talk to you again very soon guys very
soon not much longer to go now not much
longer to go now bye guys
foreign